Ich bin gerade die Treppe hochgeflitzt, weil ich festgestellt habe, ich habe gar nichts mehr zu trinken hier und ich wollte eigentlich schon Stream anklicken.
Ja eigentlich hätte ich auch langsam laufen können, ich weiß auch nicht warum ich die Treppe hochkrampfe.
Keine Ahnung.
Übrigens Leute, ich bin heute, ich weiß gar nicht was los ist.
Ups, bisschen laut, bisschen laut.
Ja so, ich weiß gar nicht was los ist und zwar, ich will heute schon wieder wandern.
Das ist doch nicht normal oder?
Exquisite.
Äh, geht bei euch, geht bei euch was?
Also bei mir zeigt Twitch nichts an.
Chat, geht bei euch irgendwas?
Also angeblich streamt er aber.
Meine Vorschau geht nicht und sonst auch nichts.
Das ist ja merkwürdig.
Also meine Vorschau ist dead gerade.
Keine Ahnung ob da krampfe, ah jetzt funkt so.
Ok Twitch, keine Ahnung was da wieder los ist.
Tja, na gut, wie auch immer.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen.
Ist eh noch keiner da.
Ich glaube Twitch leckt gerade bisschen rum.
Ich war halt schon wieder wandern.
Ich weiß gar nicht was da mit mir los ist.
Warum bin ich so viel im grünen in letzter Zeit?
Also viel, viel ist übertrieben.
Viel bedeutet 1-2 Tage die Woche oder so.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht was los ist.
Mir ist ja erst mal aufgefallen, dass es sogar ein paar Berge war.
Also naja Berge.
Also die Schweizer lachen sich jetzt kaputt.
Aber sagen wir den höchsten Berg, den wir in der Nähe haben, ist glaube ich 900 Meter.
Und wie gesagt, ich war heute wieder wandern.
Ich erkenne mich ja gar nicht wieder.
Was ist da los?
Und mir ist mal heute aufgefallen, wie anstrengend es ist berghoch zu wandern.
Ich bin ja auch nichts gewöhnt, muss man sagen.
Ich bin heute eine Stunde, eineinhalb Stunden sogar.
Eineinhalb Stunden.
Die erste halbe Stunde quasi bergunter.
Und dann nur noch berghoch eine Stunde lang.
Alter ich bin so am Arsch gewesen.
Ich habe erst mal mir noch zwei Stunden gepennt nochmal.
Das war echt anstrengend.
Achja, danach war ich natürlich noch ordentlich futtern.
Muss sein.
Guck mal.
Sieht das nicht nice aus?
Man beachtet, man beachtet dies viele Grüne.
Genau, so gesehen wohl die Sachen.
Sehr viel, sehr viel Grünes.
Aber es war echt nice, hat gut geschmeckt und es muss sein.
Ja, wie gesagt, also gerade weil ich in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen hier am rumwandern bin am Wochenende auch.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt drei Tage am Stück frei.
Es gab vorher sogar noch ein bisschen Salat, aber nicht so vielen.
Weil ich jetzt ja, ich habe ja quasi Samstag, Sonntag, Montag, ich habe frei.
Und Freitag ist jetzt auch Homeoffice.
Das heißt, ich bin auf Zeit steil.
Da kann man tatsächlich auch mal ein bisschen naturmäßig was machen.
Also das längste, wo ich unter, also wo ich, wo ich, ich bin ja absolut nichts gewöhnt.
Wo ich am Stück unterwegs war, ohne Essen waren zweieinhalb Stunden.
Danach war ich so am Arsch.
Ich gehe richtig, Patrick kann es mir vorstellen, in der Schweiz kannst du auch ordentlich wandern gehen.
Ja, runter war auch wirklich beinemäßig übelst anstrengend.
Zumindest ist mir aufgefallen, ich weiß gar nicht, sieht man den Wanderweg hier irgendwo?
Alsnau.
Diesen Berg gibt es auch überall.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es hier Bilder von gibt.
Genau, da war ich heute.
Da war ich heute und man erkennt aber nicht viel und das Fotos übelst schlecht.
Ich meine, der Turm sieht ein bisschen fail aus, ne?
Erstmal ist da so ein, ist da so ein, so ein olles Ding, ist da so ein oller Turm
und oben ist irgendwas Neues.
Ich meine, so neu ist das nicht, das sieht nur neu aus obendrauf, ist aber auch irgendwie fail.
Oder hat das einer Photoshopped?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist doch Photoshopped, oder?
Das ist massive Photoshopped, huge, huge Photoshop ist das.
Weil so sah der Turm gar nicht aus.
Aber doch, what the fuck?
Der Turm sah im Leben noch nicht so aus.
Sah der Turm echt, ich war da heute, der sah nicht so aus.
Das ist irgendein Skamars.
Der sieht im Leben nicht so aus.
Wenn du weiter so unregelmäßig streamst, kannst du als Vollzeitstream ausüben.
Ja könnte ich, will ich aber gar nicht.
Der Turm sieht wirklich so aus.
Das ist mir überhaupt nicht aufgefallen, dass der Turm so aussieht.
Na gut, wie dem auch sei.
Zumindest muss man sagen, das war echt übelst anstrengend hier berghoch.
Keine Ahnung, wandern.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es hier ein paar Bilder davon gibt.
Ja, ungefähr so.
Und das ging teilweise bis zu glaube ich 18-19% berghoch.
Und das jetzt nicht mal ganz kurz, sondern so ein Viertelstunde lang.
Dann bin ich da hoch, glaube ich.
Aber ich bin wieder angekommen.
Der Turm sieht echt ganz nett aus da drum herum.
Naja, zumindest ist es auch egal.
Ich bin nur so eingefallen gerade, weil eh das Stream noch am Anlaufen ist.
Ja Patrick, da müssen die Leute mehr donaten.
Aber ich habe halt eine Sache gemerkt.
Umso länger am Stück und umso öfters man streamt, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
was jetzt davon relevanter ist, umso mehr Subs kriegt man auch.
Ich merke das dort, also die Wochen, wo ich richtig aktiv bin
oder vielleicht sogar mal auch so den Monat, wo ich richtig aktiv bin,
da habe ich dann irgendwie keine Ahnung, bis 150 Subs mehr als im Monat.
Ist ja auch logisch irgendwie.
Also ich meine, warum sollte man abonnieren, wenn der Tube nicht aktiv ist?
Das ist ja logisch.
Ja, also wenn du 3000 Subs hast, dann kannst du easy leben.
Also aktuell habe ich glaube ich irgendwas um 150 oder sowas.
Und wenn ich übelst aktiv bin, so wie im Dezember an Weihnachten oder auch davor,
dann geht es, ich glaube das Maximalste, was ich mal hatte, war 350.
Irgendwann letztes Jahr Dezember, da war ich aber auch fast jeden Tag on.
Oder vorletztes Jahr Dezember, ich glaube letztes Jahr Dezember, weiß gar nicht mehr genau.
Also es hängt ganz stark davon ab, wie lang am Stück und wie oft man strebt.
Aber wie gesagt, es ist ja auch klar irgendwo.
Aber trotzdem, also ich will das gar nicht hauptberuflich machen.
Wenn du vier Tage die Woche acht Stunden streamen würdest, würde es locker reichen.
Wahrscheinlich, aber will ich gar nicht.
Weil dann hast du wieder das Problem, ich muss mir ja jetzt schon teilweise übelst was aus den Fingern saugen, was ich mache.
Oder ich mache so ein Stream wie heute, wo ich euch einfach mal ein super aufgeräumtes Desktop zeige und sonst nichts mache.
Aber ich muss mir teilweise schon übelst was aus den Fingern saugen, was ich mache.
Also ich habe hier was aufgeschrieben, so ein paar Sachen.
Und das müssen wir so langsam, aber sicher am ab... so ein paar Sachen haben wir davon ja auch schon gemacht.
So ein paar Sachen haben wir ja auch davon schon gemacht, so ist das nicht.
Den neuen SubX haben wir uns angeguckt, der war immer noch kacke.
Templer steht zweimal drauf, das ist knuppscheuert.
Ne, irgendwas haben wir sonst schon gemacht.
Das haben wir schon gemacht.
Oder haben wir das schon gemacht?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir schon so einen Minigit Kurs mal gemacht haben.
Das haben wir schon gemacht.
Das haben wir auch schon gemacht.
Also wisst ihr, ist jetzt nicht so als würde man da gar nichts von abarbeiten.
Passwort Manager haben wir glaube auch schon gemacht.
Wisst ihr mal, kommen wir noch sogar hin.
Reviewers, was ist das denn noch mal gewesen?
Hat das was mit diesem YouTube Dude zu tun?
PXE Software?
Das müssen wir uns auf jeden Fall mal angucken.
Weiß ich, ob ich das schon mal gezeigt habe, das habe ich letztens gefunden.
Da gibt es irgendwelche verrückten Leute, haben versucht, eine.NET-Implementierung für Microcontroller zu machen.
Das ist so eine typische Business-Stalkzeit, die absolut nichts sagend ist.
Das ist komplett bewegbar.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut es funktioniert, kommt es auf die Implementierung an.
Was ist denn?
Hä? Guck mal, da hat es einen Stern.
Ach Moment, das sind die Forks.
Okay, keine Ahnung, das wollte ich mir auf jeden Fall mal angucken in nächster Zeit.
Also das lassen wir jetzt erst mal drin stehen.
Habt ihr... Nee, pass auf XR. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die Seasons spiele.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich die Seasons spiele.
Welche Tastaturswitches findest du am besten?
Ich kann nicht sagen, welche Tastaturswitches ich nicht gut finde.
Fangen wir mal da mit an.
Ich finde die Tastaturswitches nicht gut, weil die habe ich aktuell.
Und am Wochenende ist die linke Control-Taste abgesplittert.
Die Sharp 9.NET 5 haben wir glaube ich schon drin stehen.
Das ist eines der nächsten Sachen, die wir machen.
Also eins von diesen zwei Sachen machen wir als nächstes.
Das wollte ich mir angucken, das wollte ich mir angucken.
Ach ja, und eine Sache wollte ich mir auch mal angucken.
Das ist irgendwie so ein komisches JavaScript-Framework,
was angeblich besonders kleine Sachen macht.
Da habe ich letztens ein Video zugesehen.
Das ist, also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe,
ist das ein bisschen ähnlich zu Vue.js.
Bloß, dass du nicht das Framework erst installieren musst.
Du hast quasi nur zur Entwicklungszeit dieses Framework.
Und der generiert dir daraus dann quasi statische Seiten,
die besonders klein sind.
In der Vue.js 3 kann ich heute nicht so aus dem Ärmel schütteln.
Und ich bin auch zu müde dafür, jetzt großartig Big Brain-Geschichten zu machen.
Vielleicht machen wir es doch nachher.
Wir haben ja Zeit.
Allerdings, What's New können wir uns noch mal angucken.
Seine Ego sagt, ich bin Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration
und nur wenig Ahnung, was du da machst.
Ja, aktuell mache ich ja gar nichts.
Und ich habe aktuell auch gerade keine Ahnung, was ich mache.
Ich muss mal schauen, was es Neues gibt.
Oh, die machen gute Videos, das können wir uns tatsächlich mal angucken.
Wie alle YouTube-Content-Creators jetzt Vue 3-Dinger raushaben.
Aber zurück zu den Switches, also die Sacken,
da ist mir am Wochenende die linke Control-Taste abgebrochen.
Abgebrochen, einfach so.
Aber ich habe schon gesehen, man kann sich welche nachkaufen.
Dann habe ich halt einen, wo STRG drauf steht und einer, wo...
Scheint öfters kaputt zu gehen, Control-Keys.
Guck mal, man kann...
What the fuck?
1399?
Was ist denn mit denen los?
Was?
Warum wollen die drei...
Das ist doch...
Also komm, das ist ja ein absoluter Wucherpreis.
Dann klebe ich das lieber mit ein bisschen Heißkleber.
Ach, Moment.
Das ist Amazon.com.
Warte mal, das ist Amazon.com.
Amazon.de.
Ich schicke es zurück.
Eigentlich total bescheuert.
Aber Tainser am Start 15 Monate jetzt schon.
Die Monate gehen aber auch zackig rum hier.
Eigentlich für 15 Monate.
Das ist ja fast sein Anfang an.
Und du warst auch schon da, glaube ich, bevor...
Ich kann mich an den Namen gut erinnern.
Ich warst auch schon da, bevor ich überhaupt Partner war.
Der Kram ist ja...
Alter, diese komische Song ist ja echt überall dabei.
Also, das ist ganz schön teuer.
12 Euro für zwei Control-Keys.
Das ist ja absolut Wucher.
Wisst ihr was?
Ebay.
So Dinger gibt es immer auf Ebay.
Nee, oder auch nicht.
Auf Aliexpress.
Aliexpress.
Exzellent.
Moment.
Das wird uns gucken, wenn es gleich war.
Ja, guck mal.
Hier gibt es einfach mal für 5 Euro einen kompletten Satz Keys.
Und die anderen, die wollen ernsthaft für zwei Control-Keys 13 Euro haben.
Äh, nein.
Nicht so wirklich.
Das sieht aus wie eine Ducky One, so eine Fake Ducky One.
Da die Chinesen schränken vor nichts zurück.
Habt ihr übrigens gesehen, dass Amazon eine Drohne rausbringen will?
Ja, genau hier hat man das Bild drin gehabt.
Amazon will eine Patrone rausbringen, die die Wohnung überwacht.
Ich frage mich ernsthaft, wer sich das in die Wohnung stellt.
Nee, das ist Amazon.
Nee, Ring ist Amazon, oder?
Das andere ist Google.
Ich hab vergessen, wie die Thermostat-Typen.
Nest ist Google.
Nest-Thermostate, das waren die, die ihre API umgestellt haben.
Jeder kann darauf zugreifen, auf Google Only.
Und dann hatten sie einen Tag Downtime und die Leute konnten ihre Heizung nicht mehr benutzen.
Stell euch mal vor, es ist minus 5, du wohnst in Alaska, hast eine Nest-Thermostat.
Und du kannst einen Tag lang deine Heizung nicht steuern, weil Google ihre API umstellt.
Da fragt man sich immer wieder, warum man sich den Cloud-Dienst zum Heizung steuern.
Ernsthaft, das ist der Grund, warum ich alles lokal mache.
Ich muss jetzt übrigens hier nochmal kurz was zeigen.
Das ist ja die Software, die ich verwende für meine Heimautomatisierung.
Und ich muss jetzt mal ein paar lobende Worte für die mal aussprechen.
Die schaffen das seit drei Jahren oder so.
Ich weiß nicht seit wann, ein bisschen länger, aber seit drei Jahren.
Die schaffen es alle paar Wochen, ein neues Release rauszuhauen, was ganz gut funktioniert.
Also ich kenne ja andere, die hauen was raus, das ist laufend kaputt.
Die auch laufend versuchen ihre alten Sachen auf einem aktuellen Stand zu halten.
Also sprich, die haben ihre Docs immer aktuell, die haben die alten Module für alte Sachen, machen sie immer aktuell.
Also das ist eine Software, der kann man wirklich trauen, dass die auch noch jahrelang funktioniert.
Er hat es auch nicht verkauft, obwohl das hätte verkaufen können.
Zumindest habe ich das da rein interpretiert.
Der wurde ja eine Zeit lang von Ubiquiti gesponsort.
Und wahrscheinlich hat er auch die ein oder andere Verkaufsangebote gehabt.
Da hat er mal ein paar Reddit-Posts durchblicken lassen.
Also ich glaube, da kann man sich wirklich drauf...
Also ich verlasse mich da zumindest drauf.
IO-Broker wollte ich mir tatsächlich auch mal angucken, Salgur.
Aber was mich an IO-Broker abschreckt, ist das Web-Interface.
Zumindest das letzte Mal, als ich mir IO-Broker angeguckt habe.
Weil...
Okay, also keine Ahnung, ob das wie das Web-Interface mittlerweile ist.
Ja, genau das hier.
Das hat mich übelst abgeschreckt, weil...
Das muss ich auch meine Mutter verwenden.
Und ich kann die in sowas nichts rumklicken lassen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Und da mal zum Vergleich...
Also es sah mal so aus. Es kann sein, dass das neu ist.
Ich habe mir das vor zwei Jahren oder so angeguckt.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Jenkins, ja.
Und guckt euch mal da im Vergleich die Home Assistant-Oberfläche an.
Das ist ein ganz anderes Ding.
Also da kann man wirklich auch irgendwie einem Noob...
Was weiß ich, Frau, Freundin, Mutter, Oma, was auch immer...
Vater, der keine Ahnung von Technik hat, dem kann man auch sowas hinsetzen.
Okay, wenn du das Licht anmachen willst, klickst du da drauf.
Und das ist noch ziemlich unübersichtlich.
Es gibt Leute, das ist übrigens auch ein riesen Vorteil von...
Man kann auch so Raumpläne machen und sowas.
Das ist übrigens auch ein riesen Vorteil von Home Assistant,
dass viele Leute richtig gute Konfics, zum Beispiel der hier,
auf GitHub geshared haben.
Der übertreibt es aber total.
Er hat wirklich für alles 30 Milliarden unter Files.
Und bei dem blickst du eigentlich auch noch mal richtig durch.
Aber er hat es schön übersichtlich gemacht.
Übrigens, was mich ja letztens gefreut hat, ist...
Übrigens, ich gucke mir gleich die Chat-Fragen an.
Ich habe gesehen, da waren ein paar Sachen dabei.
Und wir haben ja vor einem Jahr ungefähr im Keller,
im Stream zusammen, die Heizungüberwachung gebaut.
Und ich habe die Heizung jetzt wieder eingeschaltet.
Die war jetzt ja ein paar Monate aus, weil Sommer war.
Die habe ich gestern wieder eingeschaltet. Jetzt guckt mal.
Ich glaube, das ist fast schon ein Jahr her.
Nee, nein, stimmt. Patrick, du hast recht.
Das ist nicht ein Jahr. Ich glaube, das ist ein Dreivierteljahr her.
Das haben wir Anfang des Jahres gemacht.
So, guckt mal. Heizung auslesen. Wunderbar.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen... Moment.
Last... Last... Seven Days.
Guckt hier. Aus, aus, aus, aus, aus.
Und hier habe ich eingeschaltet. Und wie gut das funktioniert.
Ich bin da tatsächlich echt begeistert von...
Das war ja so ein bisschen behelfsmäßig zusammengestrickt am Anfang.
Danach habe ich es nochmal ordentlich gemacht.
Und das funktioniert einfach richtig gut.
Ich kann jetzt... Der Typ... Ich hatte ja den Heizungsinstallateur hier.
Weil die Heizung hatte einen Lack. Die war kaputt.
Und hat Druck verloren und fragt mich nicht alles mögliche Zeug.
Und da wollte er mir das hier verkaufen.
Tja, wenn ich muss. Ich glaube, das da. Ich glaube, das wollte er mir verkaufen.
Und das ist nur ein Teil. Du brauchst da zwei Sachen.
Du brauchst eine Basisstation und du brauchst irgendwie...
So. Und das wollte er mir verkaufen.
Und dann habe ich ihm das Tablet gezeigt.
Und da hat er halt gemeint, ja, okay, dann nicht.
Das ist besser als das, was die haben.
Ja, und die Sache ist halt die, dass diese Adapter an die gleiche Schnittstelle geht,
wie man Raspberry Pi Zero im Keller.
Das heißt, ich könnte eh nur eins von beiden anschließen.
Ach ja, übrigens, sein Verkaufsargument, warum ich mir lieber das von ihm holen sollte, ist...
Ich meine, der kennt mich halt nicht. Für mich ist das eigentlich genau das Gegenteil gewesen.
Sein Verkaufsargument war...
Ah ja, gut, dass er mir das verkaufen will. Das will keine Sau mehr haben. Alles gut.
Sein Verkaufsargument war, dann kann er bei sich...
Genau, in der Cloud, dann kann er bei sich sehen, ob meine Heizung einen Fehler hat.
Und er wahrscheinlich kriegt der Position.
Aber ich dachte mir so, wenn meine Heizung nicht geht, dann sage ich dem schon Bescheid.
Ich meine, was kann... Okay.
Also wenn die Heizung kaputt ist und die Heizung heizt nicht mehr, dann merke ich das ja.
So, und die Typen sind ja auch absolut nicht happy damit.
Happy damit.
Ja.
Zumindest, das ist Müll. Also kauft euch nicht. Macht lieber hier so eine Raspberry Pi Zero Geschichte.
Und zu der Frage, die eben im Chat gekommen ist, und zwar...
Wie greifst du die Werte vom Kessel ab?
Ich will jetzt, die Leute, die dabei waren, nicht zu sehr langweilen. Deswegen erzähle ich es nur noch mal kurz.
Also diese Wiesmann-Heizung, die haben eine Schnittstelle vorne dran.
Ich weiß nicht, was du für eine Heizung hast, falls du überhaupt eine Heizung von denen hast.
Die haben eine... Die haben eine Schnittstelle vorne dran.
So, dieses Kabel brauchste und... Mal gucken, ob wir... Ist ein schönes Bild.
Genau, so sieht das vorne an der Heizung aus.
So, hier, genau. Da ist so ein Wiesmann-V-Loch.
Keine Ahnung.
Da macht man so ein Optolink-Kabel rein. Und das kann man eine Raspberry Pi anschließen.
Es gibt garantiert das Video dazu, wie ich das gemacht habe, nämlich im Archiv.
Da musst du mal gucken.
Ich habe hier einen Archiv, wo alles drin ist.
Das ist der Archiv.
Zack.
So, und im Archiv kannst du gucken, wie die Streamtitel waren.
Da musst du mal gucken, Wiesmann...
Nee, Heizung... Hier.
Heizung im Keller auslesen mit Pi Zero und V-Control-D.
Und das ist... Im Februar haben wir das gemacht. Ja, hier.
Diese zwei Streams, das da und das da.
Worum geht's? Ich zeige gerade, wie ich meine Heizung gebaut habe, damit ich meine Heizung auslesen kann.
Hat jemand im Chat gefragt, wie ich das mache.
Aber was du dazu unbedingt brauchst, ist dieses Kabel.
Allerdings, das Kabel kann man sich auch selbst bauen. Das ist ziemlich simpel.
Aber der Preis ist halt der Witz. Ich meine, das ist 70 Euro.
Die haben echt den Arsch offen.
Überlegt euch mal, das ist ein USB-Anschluss mit zwei Infrarot-LEDs drin.
Das war's.
Wie wäre es mit einem Tinder-Bot und einem Grill zu finden?
Was sollte ein Tinder-Bot machen?
Immer dauerhaft nach rechts mischen, oder wie?
Egal, was es ist. Accept, accept, nee, accept, accept.
AI-Chatbot.
Also quasi so ein Poser-Chatbot, der oder so ein...
irgendein Big-Brain-Chatbot,
der die wichtigsten Sachen schon vorher abcheckt.
Das kenne ich, Patrick.
Übrigens, Chatbot.
Hab ich euch mal erzählt, wo ich auf der Arbeit einen Fake-Chatbot gebaut habe,
den alle so geil fanden?
Bisschen Cool-Story-Bob-Zeit.
Der Snagger kommt morgen hier. Poggers.
Ich hab immer noch nicht geantwortet auf Twitter.
Also wir hatten mal auf der Arbeit so ein Projekt,
wo man Verbesserungsvorschläge machen konnte.
Und dann haben sie sich alle mit Überschlagen nach dem Motto,
oh, das wird Next Level.
Das haben die ja wirklich erzählt.
Die sind dann komplett eskaliert, die Stonks-Leute bei uns.
Das wird dann Next Level und das machen wir alles.
Oh, wie geil die Vorschläge sind.
Und im Endeffekt ratet mal, was sie davon umgesetzt haben.
Also, nix.
Die haben sich monatlang überschlagen, wie geil das ist.
Aber als es darum ging, was umzusetzen, passiert nix.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das bei euch aus der Firma kennt,
aber bei uns ist das ziemlich Standard eigentlich.
Man macht immer Riesen-Tamm-Tamm.
So nach dem Motto, wir starten jetzt die Qualitätsoffensive.
Wir starten jetzt irgendwie die Zufriedenheitsoffensive.
Qualität am Arbeitsplatz, Next Level, Verbesserungs-Sachen und so.
Dann überschlagen die sich immer richtig und gehen voll ab.
Und da gibt es dann irgendwelche Kick-Off-Geschichten,
wo sich irgendein Stonks-Mann vorne hinstellt und dann sagt,
ja, wir haben jetzt die nächsten Monate hier ein tolles Programm und bla und so.
Und flippen total aus.
Und dann gibt es irgendwelche Arbeitsgruppen dazu
und da flippen auch immer alle total aus.
Und dann kommt dann bei diesen Arbeitsgruppen irgendwas raus
und dann werden dann noch Ergebnisse präsentiert
und dann flippen auch alle total aus.
Und alle sind total happy und finden es total geil.
Und dann kommt irgendwann der Punkt, wo es dann irgendwie einen Auftrag gibt,
Umsetzen und ab da passiert nix mehr.
Ab da ist quasi komplett Post-Champ.
Dann hört es schlagartig auf.
Also das geht echt von 100 für alles finden wir geil zu 0.
Dann ist vorbei.
So war das bei diesen Geschichten auch.
Und ich habe damals den Vorschlag gemacht in diesem Verbesserungsvorschlag-Workshop-Gedöns.
Ich habe mich sogar einmal in meinem Leben für so eine Arbeitsgruppe angemeldet.
Also ich kenne mich ja, so etwas mache ich ja normalerweise nicht.
Und dann kam da raus, okay, was wir vorschlagen.
Also warst du auch komplett hyped.
Nee, ich wollte mal live dabei sein, wie es nicht funktioniert.
Ansonsten habe ich ja immer die Sache nur vom Seitenrand beobachtet
und darüber gelästert, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Ich wollte mal live dabei sein, wie es nicht funktioniert.
Also mir war von Anfang an klar, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Die Calls, drei Monate, exzellent.
Subscription.
So, zumindest, um das mal fertig zu erzählen, da haben wir eine Arbeitsgruppe gemacht.
Und da war natürlich, man kann ja nicht einfach fünf Mitarbeiter zusammenschmeißen
und die Arbeitsgruppe machen lassen.
Selbstverständlich hatten wir natürlich externe Beratung dabei,
die uns erklärt hat, wie man so Arbeitsgruppen macht.
Ich meine, es wäre ja auch nicht auszudenken, wenn man die Leute einfach Arbeitsgruppe machen lässt.
Also, da brauchst du schon externe Berater dabei, die dir erstmal erklären,
wie man Arbeitsgruppen macht.
Also sprich, da war irgendwie irgendeine, ja wie nennt man sowas,
irgendeine Beratungskonsultingfirma mit dabei.
Welche Fachrechnung hast du als, ich habe Fachinformatik und Systemintegration mal gelernt vor,
keine Ahnung, 15 Jahren oder so.
So, und dieser Typ von dieser Konsultingfirma, der hat es auch nicht schlecht gemacht.
Man muss sagen, der war halt sehr visiert im Buzzword Umgang.
Also, da habe ich zum ersten Mal richtig echtes Scrum, so wie man es machen sollte, gemacht.
Wir machen das zwar in der Firma auch, aber wir machen das nicht richtig.
Wir sagen nur, es ist Scrum, aber eigentlich ist es nur im Kreis stehen, ohne sich hinsetzen zu dürfen.
Vielleicht, da frage ich mal, kennt ihr das auch?
Das war in der alten Firma beim Provider, wo ich gearbeitet habe, auch so.
Man sagt, dass man was macht, weil das gerade cool ist, aber man macht es eigentlich gar nicht.
Also es gibt, ich glaube nicht, dass das die einzige Firma ist, wo ich bin.
Die sagen, hey wir machen Scrum und in Wirklichkeit steht man im Kreis,
ohne dass man sich hinsetzen darf und das nennt man dann Scrum, was mit der eigentlichen Sache überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Theoretisch kannst du dich aufs Klo setzen oder so, das ist eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Genau, Patrick, er schreibt, genau, sie nennen das Scrum, machen aber ein konservatives Projekt.
Also im Prinzip sind das dann wieder irgendwelche Meetings, wo es darum geht, wer mehr sagt gewinnt,
was ja eigentlich bewiesenermaßen scheiße ist, aber da läuft es dann wieder drauf raus.
So, wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Genau, warte mal, warte mal, wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Genau, also da haben wir zum ersten Mal Scrum gemacht, so wie es eigentlich gedacht ist.
Und meine Güte, ey, der Beratertyp, der ging voll ab.
Der hat uns dann erzählt, ich krieg nur noch die Hälfte zusammen, das ist ja auch schon wieder ein Jahr her oder so.
Der hat dann erzählt, dass die unterschiedlichen Scrum Master vernetzen sich in einzelnen Tribes miteinander und sowas.
Das wäre echt Passwort Bingo Extrem.
Wie bescheuert sich das schon anhören?
Die Scrum Master vernetzen sich in einzelnen Tribes.
Also was damit gemeint ist, also was damit gemeint ist, ist folgendes.
Man hat verschiedene Teams, Achtung, Huge Pain Skills.
Was damit gemeint ist, ist folgendes, also man hat verschiedene Teams, so hier, Team A.
Wow, exzellent, sieht jetzt aus wie so ein vollgeiles Team, Team B, Team C.
Und da hast du die einzelnen Leute im Team, exzellent.
Und irgendwie so ein bisschen zur Aufsicht und zum, was weiß ich, ich war so ein Scrum Master, genau,
hast du hier irgendwie so ein Scrum Master oben drauf, so.
So, und das hier ist ja alles so in einem Team, drei Baguettes.
Und wenn man sich jetzt untereinander vernetzt, dann nennt man das in Scrum, das ist ein Tribe.
Also weil das hier ist quasi ein Tribe und die Tribes vernetzen sich untereinander.
Ich, also, was auch immer die sich das ausgedacht haben.
Zumindest der Typ, der konnte halt richtig geile Buzzwords um sich schmeißen.
Das ist Baguette Scrum.
Ähm, ja, und, ja, und da haben wir das zum ersten Mal richtig gemacht.
Das war auch eigentlich wirklich eine coole Geschichte, dass man mal auf einer Besprechung war.
Und es so gemacht hat, wie man es eigentlich machen sollte, dass es auch vollkommen okay war,
wenn man gesagt hat, es gibt nichts Neues.
Ja, so, zumindest der Verbesserungsvorschlag von mir waren zwei Sachen,
was rausgekommen ist in diesem Verbesserungswerk, äh, Arbeitsgruppe, in der Verbesserungsarbeitsgruppe.
Also, ich hab zwei Vorschläge gemacht.
Einmal, dass man eine automatisch generiertes Webfront entbastelt,
wo alle Systeme, und ich meine damit alle Systeme, die man betreibt,
automatisch, äh, grafisch aufbereitet werden.
Also sprich, man guckt, dass man die 30.000 Quellen, die man hat,
wo jeder irgendwo ein bisschen aufgeschrieben hat, wo die einzelnen Systeme stehen.
Also, so einfach meine ich jetzt nicht Kleinsysteme.
Und was man da hat, dass man das irgendwie versucht zusammenzuschmeißen
und dann einen Webfront draufsetzt, dass man mal eine schöne Karte hat,
wo man rein und raus scrollen kann, was man hat und wozu das Ganze gehört.
Ich hab das, äh, ich hab sogar einen Prototyp damals gebastelt,
hier mit diesem, mit diesem Grafik-Framework.
Übrigens mittlerweile nicht mehr maintained.
Da hab ich dann sowas hier, sowas, sowas in der Richtung hier gebaut.
Versuch's euch mal zu zeigen.
Äh, Network, ja, ein bisschen, ein bisschen sowas in der Richtung hab ich versucht zu bauen, ja.
Also da hat man dann verschiedene Systeme gehabt.
Also quasi das hier ist außen das System A und dazu gehört Service A, B, C, D mit Server X, Y, Z.
Sowas in der Richtung hab ich dann da gebaut
und je nachdem mit verschiedenen Detailgrats beim rein und raus zoomen.
Das war nicht großartig schwer und hat eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert.
So, das war der erste Vorschlag von mir.
Ich fand das eigentlich ganz gut und ziemlich gut umzusetzen.
So, und wisst ihr, was man gemacht hat?
Also das ist ja der erste Vorschlag von mir, der voll in die Hose gegangen ist.
Stattdessen, anstatt sowas, sowas zu machen,
ähm, was, also sag mal so, ich fand meinen Vorschlag war relativ einfach.
Man hätte einfach nur, und das hat, das war zu 90% mehr oder weniger fertig,
es hätten bloß noch ein paar Teams mitmachen müssen.
Man hätte alles einfach nur Hostnamen und Systemzugehörigkeit
irgendwie in irgendein Jason-Format packen müssen
und dann hättest man Frontend fressen können und gut ist.
Das wäre ziemlich einfach gewesen.
Das hätte man die einmal, oder man, irgendeine SQLite oder so vollkommen wurscht,
das hätte man dann einmal die Nacht abdecken lassen und gut ist.
So, das hätte relativ gut funktioniert
und das hat auch schon in der Demo relativ gut funktioniert.
Und da waren alle von Begeisterung und sagten, oh, ist das toll
und das, das müssen wir unbedingt weiterverfolgen.
Und wisst ihr, was sie jetzt gemacht haben?
Die haben sich für das Gleiche ein extrem krass overengineertes Confluence-Plugin gekauft,
was das macht.
Und das Confluence-Plugin kann keine Daten ordentlich importieren.
Das heißt, anstatt, dass sie das wie in meinem Frontend benutzt hätten,
also sprich, wir hätten den Kram genommen, den wir haben,
hätten das irgendwie in Jason-Datei umgewurstet, Frontend drauf und gut wär's,
haben die jetzt sich ein Confluence-Plugin gekauft.
Vielleicht fällt mir noch gleich ein, wie das heißt.
Da können wir uns mal die Demo zu angucken.
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt.
Visualize.
Vielleicht komm ich nachher noch drauf.
So, und dann haben sie festgestellt, dass man die Sachen gar nicht richtig importieren kann.
Inside, exakt, Patrick, Inside heißt das Ding.
Du kennst den Kram wohl anscheinend schon.
Ja, genau, guckt's euch mal an.
Entdeckt ihr die Ähnlichkeit zu meinem Frontend?
Also erkennt man da eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit.
Das ist halt die bisschen schönere Variante.
So, und dann ist ihnen aufgefallen, dass die in dieses komische Confluence-Plugin
ihre Sachen gar nicht richtig importieren können.
Und deswegen haben die jetzt ein Team quasi abgestellt, aus extern natürlich.
Ein Typ und drei Assistenten-Mädels dazu abgestellt, die alles von Hand,
so was wie hier, genau, die alles von Hand dort eintragen.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Man hätte einfach unser altes Zeug mehr oder weniger 90% zu nehmen können,
ein bisschen drumherum gewurstet, noch die anderen Sachen in irgendein Jason-Format konvertieren,
das hätte funktioniert.
Aber nein, man hat sich lieber so ein geiles Plugin gekauft.
Und ich meine, das ist natürlich schon richtig krass.
Also wenn das hier nicht huge stonks ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Oh, jetzt, da geht einer drauf ab, hier, Host 1, Berechtigungsschema.
Aha, das ist, da flippen sie aus.
Da flippen sie aus, wenn sie sowas hier haben.
Warum habt ihr so viele Externe?
Das hat verschiedene Gründe.
Hauptsächlich, dass sie die nach Projekten instant wieder loswerden.
Aber der hauptsächliche Grund ist eigentlich, dass, also das ist so,
was ich mir zusammenreime, sind irgendwelche betrieblichen Gründe.
Zum Beispiel, dass wenn du zu viel Internet hast,
du mehr Betriebsräte brauchst und dass du dann andere Vorgaben erfüllen musst
und dass du dann andere Sachen machen musst.
Das ist einfach unterm Strich für die einfacher mit Externen,
obwohl die viel mehr kosten, ja.
Brauchst du auch gerade etwas, was übel stonks ist? Exzellent.
Kannst du einfach eine Frage antworten?
Äh, welche denn?
Dr. X?
Ah, hier, also.
Ups, was denn?
Will man einfach Berufserfahrung oder braucht man da...
Nein, du brauchst keine Fortbildung.
Es ist halt die Sache, ob du irgendwas kannst, was gebraucht wird.
Generell kannst du eine Seite empfehlen,
wo du aus wie Fortbildung und Karrieremöglichkeiten für Physik zusammengefasst...
Äh, nee.
Keine Ahnung, wo es sowas gibt.
Aber ich glaube, da gibt es auch keine festgeschriebenen Sachen.
Also, wie gesagt, ich habe vor 15 Jahren noch mal
an der fachinformatischen Systemintegration Ausbildung gemacht,
aber wie das bei mir gelaufen ist, war folgendermaßen.
Aber ich muss das andere eigentlich erst noch kurz fertig erzählen.
Also, ich kürze mal ab.
Ich beantworte das gleich fertig.
Ich kürze mal ab, um mit dieser Scrum und externen Geschichte nochmal schnell zu enden.
Also, mein erster Vorschlag war ja so ein Grafik-Ding.
Das hat man nicht gemacht.
Ich habe jetzt so ein overengineertes Confluence-Ding gekauft.
Und mein zweiter Vorschlag,
und das ist das, worauf ich eigentlich ursprünglich raus wollte,
mein zweiter Vorschlag war,
wir sollten doch mal einen ordentlichen Closar erstellen,
weil, vielleicht ist das bei euch in der Firma auch so,
wir kürzen Sachen gerne ab.
Also, vor allem haben wir Abkürzungen, die doppelt belegt sind.
Also, wir kürzen quasi alles ab,
und die Sachen sind auch noch doppelt belegt.
Und ganz Deutschland versteht, wir hatten zum Beispiel DFB als Abkürzung.
Da versteht so ziemlich in Deutschland jeder was drunter, was anderes, also was mit Fußball drunter.
Bei uns war DFB irgendwie sowas wie Durchbruch für Berufsstarter oder sowas.
Ich kriege es nicht mal genau zusammen.
Also, wir kürzen den Kram halt total beknackt ab.
So, und da habe ich einen Vorschlag gemacht,
wir sollten einen ordentlichen Closar machen,
und da haben wir gesagt, aber man sollte folgende Punkte beachten.
Erstens, also man kann da nichts Falsches eintragen,
man soll die Leute dazu anhalten, so ein bisschen Wiki ähnlich,
dass man einfach, wenn man eine Idee hat, das reinschreibt,
und man hat halt ein Moderationsteam,
dass sich das bei den neuen Einträgen ab und zu mal anguckt, wenn sie Zeit haben.
Also sprich, dass die Leute möglichst einfach Sachen eintragen können,
weil man muss es eigentlich den Leuten einfacher machen,
es nicht, also so einfach einzutragen in Closar,
als dass es auf Dauer ätzender wird, wenn man es nicht einträgt.
So, zumindest war das meine Idee dahinter.
So, und da habe ich gesagt, okay, man muss es den Leuten möglichst einfach machen,
die Sachen da einzutragen, und dass das funktioniert.
Dazu muss man den Kram noch möglichst breit treten,
auf jeder Teamrunde, mindestens ein halbes Jahr lang,
dass es den Kram gibt, weil sonst macht keiner mit.
Ja, und noch so ein paar Punkte.
So, und eine Sache, die ich dann auch noch vorgeschlagen habe,
weil das Ganze ja übelst hier Next Level Big Brain Ideen sein sollten,
war ich okay, und man könnte sogar noch einen Chatbot machen,
den man nach Closarsachen fragen kann.
Also zum Beispiel, was bedeutet DFB oder sowas.
Und da habe ich auch eine Demo programmiert, und Leute, ich sage euch,
das war die größte Fake Demo aller Zeiten.
Also ich habe eine Sache wirklich gemacht im Hintergrund.
Ich habe irgendeinen Python Machine Learning Textverarbeitungsbot genommen
und habe dem fünf Testfragen trainiert, die konnte er dann auch gut,
und das konnte er dann auch in unterschiedlichsten Abwandlungen.
Also den konnte man dann fragen, was heißt DFB, was bedeutet DFG,
ich weiß nicht, was DFB heißt und sowas in der Richtung.
Konnte man die fragen.
Das hat ganz gut funktioniert, aber die Sache war die,
du konntest sie halt nur nach zwei Begriffen fragen,
und alle anderen Sachen, die du ihn fragen konntest,
waren einfach übel scripted und fake.
Ich habe zum Beispiel gesagt, ja, wir mussten es dann präsentieren,
und auf der Präsentation habe ich gesagt, okay, jetzt gibt es noch ein paar Demos,
da habe ich erstmal die Demo gezeigt mit der Systemübersicht,
und dann habe ich die Demo gezeigt mit dem Chatbot,
und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, das Schöne ist,
wenn man so einen Chatbot hat, den kann man dann auch relativ einfach erweitern,
und ich habe dann so als Gag eingebaut noch, sowas gibt es heute zu essen,
und dann hat er in der Chatbot geantwortet mit dem,
was es letzte Woche in der Kantine gab,
und bei der Gelegenheit habe ich dann auch gleich noch dazu gesagt,
ja, und dann sieht man, wie wichtig das ist, dass auch jemand guckt,
dass die Daten unten drunter aktuell sind,
weil das ist das Essen von letzter Woche.
Und das war komplett fake, das Ding.
Also bis auf diese zwei Fragen konnte der nichts beantworten.
Alle anderen Sachen, ich habe so 7, 8 Sachen in der Demo gezeigt,
waren komplett hardcoded, scripted,
und auch nicht mal serverseitig scripted,
wenn irgendjemand auf diesen Bot gegangen wäre und hätte Seitenansicht gemacht,
der hätte einfach 7 Ifs gesehen mit der Frage,
if contains, if contains, if contains, dann das.
Das war so extrem zusammengefängt, keiner hat es gemerkt,
und ich war alle super begeistert davon, super begeistert,
fanden das alle gerne und sagten, ja, das machen wir, das machen wir,
und Chat, was meint ihr?
Haben wir es gemacht?
Nix.
Exakt, wir haben das nicht umgesetzt, und noch besser,
den Vorschlag mit Closar und dass das einfach sein soll,
haben wir sogar noch, haben sie jetzt noch total übertrieben.
Wir haben jetzt zwar einen neuen Closar bekommen,
aber man muss ein Ticket an ein Moderationsteam aufmachen,
das die eventuell einen Begriff aufnehmen.
Und was meint ihr, wie viele Beteiligungen es gab,
seit es den neuen Closar seit, glaube ich, Februar gibt?
Das haben, glaube ich, fünf Leute, die sich beteiligt,
und das sind die üblichen Streber, die überall mal ein Like geben.
Kennt ihr das, die Leute, die immer Sachen im Confluence liken,
so nach dem Motto, neuer Blogpost von der Geschäftsführung,
Person A liked das, Person B liked das,
und das sind immer die Kleinigen, die das liken.
Also es haben, keine Ahnung, fünf Leute oder so beim Closar mitgemacht.
Ich meine, man muss sich das mal vorstellen.
Unser Vorschlag war, macht es den Leuten so einfach wie möglich,
es ist auch erst mal egal, ob da irgendwas Sinnvolles drinsteht,
man guckt da einfach ab und zu mal drüber, und gut ist.
Ja, wir haben, KeeperX, wir haben einen Closar, wir haben einen Closar,
und das nennt sich sogar IT-Closar, das ist auf der Startseite im Confluence.
Mit dem Unterschied, es macht halt keines Sau mit.
Da steht nicht mehr die üblichsten Dinger drin.
Das ist total, total, total beknackt.
So, und jetzt musst du, und jetzt musst du ein Ticket machen,
dass du da einen Begriff rein kriegst, so total, total hingeblieben im Endeffekt.
Macht, macht keiner mit. So.
Und der Vorschlag von uns damals war auch, okay,
man sollte das rein intern verwenden, weil dann ist es ja egal,
ob da auch mal Mist drinsteht. So, und jetzt haben wir einen Closar,
der wohl auch teilweise von außen erreichbar ist,
und schon war die Rechtsabteilung am Start und hat gesagt, Moment,
das geht ja auch nicht.
Wenn in dem Closar Sachen drinstehen, und das ist teilweise von außen erreichbar,
ja dann musst du nicht nur ein Ticket aufmachen mit einem neuen Begriff,
da musst du auch noch an die Rechts-, also da musst du an die Teamsausicht
auch noch in die Rechtsabteilung wenden, ob dieser Begriff in dieser Art und Weise
im Closar überhaupt aufgeführt werden darf.
Also kein Wunder, also es macht keine Sau mit im Endeffekt, ja.
So, aber jetzt kommen wir, oh fuck, ich hab schon wieder
meine Control-Taste verloren.
Ich hab schon wieder meine Control-Taste verloren.
Was ist denn hier los?
Okay, also jetzt kommen wir mal zu eigentlichen Problemen,
also jetzt kommen wir mal zu eigentlichen Fragen von TrexStream,
übrigens exzellenten Name.
Also genau, das ist nämlich ein bisschen umfangreichere Frage,
da kann ich relativ viel zu sagen.
Also nochmal seine Frage ist, wie wird man eigentlich vom Fachinformat
zum DevOps?
Einfache Berufserfahrung oder braucht man eine bestimmte Fortbildung?
Generell kannst du eine Seite empfehlen, wo sowas wie Fortbildung
und Karrieremöglichkeiten für Physik zusammengefasst sind.
Also, das letzte kann ich relativ einfach beantworten, gibt's nicht,
also ist mir nicht bekannt.
Ähm, wüsste ich nicht.
Zumal es auch so ist, das ist ziemlich im Fluss.
Also heute kommen sie mit DevOps, Fullstack, Data Science
und sonst was an.
Gestern waren sie mit Cloud-Engineer und sonst was dran
und morgen kommt wieder was anderes.
Also das ist halt extrem im Fluss, da gibt's eigentlich nichts.
So, und diese Frage kann man ja ganz allgemein stellen.
Wie kommt man quasi von dem, was man irgendwie mal gelernt hat,
zu dem, was man vielleicht machen will oder zu was anderem?
Und die hauptsächliche Sache ist,
und das ist eigentlich auch das, was ich bei allen Sachen sage,
das Allerwichtigste ist, dass man sich dann
von dem, was man eigentlich mal gelernt hat,
zu dem, was man eigentlich mal gelernt hat,
das Allerwichtigste ist, dass man sich dafür interessiert.
Weil wenn man sich dafür interessiert,
dann ist das auch was, wo man sich privat mit beschäftigt
und wo man ganz gut fühlt mit der Zeit.
Und wenn man in was ganz gut ist
und wenn man, Consulting-mäßig, bedeutet das natürlich auch,
man muss ein bisschen was können und dann besonders gut tun können,
dass man was kann.
Dann ist die Chance, dass man in dem Bereich arbeiten kann auch höher
und wenn man in dem Bereich arbeiten kann, dann wird man auch besser,
was dann irgendwie ein bisschen zu sich passt.
So, und die klassische Fachinformatiker-Systemintegration
gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Also es gibt die Ausbildung Fachinformatiker-Systemintegration
noch, aber das, was man da...
Mal gucken, was die IHK...
Mal gucken, was die IHK mittlerweile dazu schreibt.
Also so die reine Server-Admin-Geschichte,
wie das...
Mal gucken wir uns mal an, was die dazu schreiben.
Also sprich, was man da früher darunter verstand,
also nach dem Motto, du bist reiner Server-Admin
oder irgendwelche Operating-Geschichten, das ist schon lange nicht mehr so.
Also so reine Server-Admin-Tätigkeiten gibt es eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Das einzige, wo ich das bei uns aus der Firma kenne,
ist aus dem Datenbank-Bereich.
Da hast du wirklich welche, die den ganzen Tag nur auf Datenbanken gucken
und aus dem IBM-Großrechner-Bereich.
Da hast du auch Leute, die gucken die ganze Zeit auf so eine...
Auf so ein Ding hier.
So. Jetzt gucken die sich den ganzen Tag an.
Exzellent. Und dann haben sie in der Konsol noch
dieses Fadenkreuz, wo man Dinger anklicken kann.
Ja, hier. Sowas. Das ist so ein tolles Fadenkreuz haben wir dann.
Also wie gesagt, so die klassische Fachinformatik gibt es eigentlich immer.
Mal gucken, was da das Arbeitsamt zuschreibt.
Wir haben RFC
als Abkürzung. Also wundert mich nicht.
Wir haben ja alles Mögliche als Abkürzung. Aber RFC
kenne ich noch gar nicht. Oder ich habe es schon wieder verdrängt,
was RFC bei uns ist. Also was schreiben die denn hier?
Fachinformatikerinnen
der Fachrichtigungssystemintegration
realisieren, Kundenspielen, bla bla bla bla bla.
Hierfür vernetzen sie harten Software zum komplexen System.
Also das ist so ein bisschen die klassische Netzwerktechnik
der Software hat eine Geschichte. Die gibt es
in der Art und Weise eigentlich immer weniger.
Die gibt es immer weniger.
Also sprich, wenn du was anderes machen willst, das
wichtigste ist.
Das wichtigste, das wichtigste ist. Ach stimmt.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Ich erinnere mich.
Ich erinnere mich wieder. Stimmt. Das ist ja morgen wieder.
Da muss ich ja morgen wieder hin.
Aufs Request for Change.
Da muss ich ja morgen wieder hinhocken. Oder virtuell
im Teams zumindest hinhocken.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt darauf, was da ist da raus.
Ja, ich habe schon wieder ganz verdrängt, dass wir auch RFC doppelt belegt haben.
So.
Ja, um jetzt mal ganz kurz auf die Frage hier einzugehen
von Dragstream. Also das wichtigste ist, dass du dich dafür interessierst.
Ich habe mich nicht privat mit
Jenkins damals beschäftigt, mit Git damals
beschäftigt oder mich allgemein fürs
Wie bekommt man Sachen auf unterschiedliche Systeme drauf?
Hätte ich mich nicht für Programmieren interessiert, sei es
jetzt Frontend, Backend mit C-Sharp, bisschen Go,
JavaScript, Ruby, alle möglichen Geschichten,
würde ich das wahrscheinlich heute nicht machen.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt, wenn du dich dafür
baust, du ja auch mehr oder weniger Know-How in dem Bereich auf.
Und dann hängt es einfach davon ab, in welcher Firma du bist.
Wenn die Leute suchen, mehr oder weniger
rutscht man eher durch
Umstände in solche Positionen.
Also es ist selten, zumindest bei uns selten so, dass die
mal groß sagen, wir brauchen jemand, der das und das kann.
Meistens ist es eher so, dass
das mal aufschlägt irgendwo und man sich dann halt drum kümmert.
Und vielleicht kennt ihr das, sobald man sich mal um irgendwas
gekümmert hat, ist man sofort dafür zuständig.
Keine Ahnung, ob das bei euch auch so ist, aber bei uns ist das ganz oft so.
Also man
Man nimmt sich irgendwas und sagt, ja, ich gucke mir das mal kurz an.
Und dann machst du so, dass es wieder geht.
Und dann kommt zwei Wochen einer
später zu dir und sagt, Max, Max, Max, ich habe gehört,
du kümmerst dich da drum.
You touch it, you own it, genau.
Da
kam, da hat mich letztens jemand angerufen.
Okay, letztens ist ein bisschen länger her. Aber da hat mich letztens jemand
angerufen, da hat so gemeint, Herr Max,
ich kriege den Biolog nicht mal ganz, so ganz,
so ganz zusammen. Aber da hat angerufen, Herr Max,
der hat das so ganz merkwürdig ausgerichtet.
Kümmern Sie sich oder
kennen Sie sich mit den
Hostkrippen aus?
Dann hat mich jemand gefragt, ja, wie, welche Hostkrippe, da gibt es total viele
Möglichkeiten. Ja, die Hostkrippe, mit denen Sie sich auskennen,
war dann die zweite Antwort von ihm.
Total,
in der ersten Frage hat er quasi gefragt, ob ich mich damit auskenne.
Und dann hat er gesagt, als Frage darauf, welche,
ja, die Skripte, mit denen ich mich auskenne.
Und dann hat er die ganze Sache mal die Finger drin.
Und schon hast du es, warte mal, habe ich das nicht
sogar auf Twitter gepostet?
So Sachen, so merkwürdige
Dialoge poste ich immer ganz gern mal auf Twitter.
Hier!
Genau, so, also das ist nicht, da sind natürlich auch ein paar Sätze dazwischen
gefallen, das ist nicht immer original so. Aber so in der Richtung
lief dieser Anruf ab. Hallo Herr Max, sind Sie zuständig für die
Skripte? Habe ich halt gesagt, hä, was genau, da gibt es total viele
Möglichkeiten. Und dann hat der Anrufer gesagt, ja, ich meine die Skripte,
um die Sie sich kümmern. Alles klar.
Und ich hatte, äh, nee, wahrscheinlich kümmere ich mich da nicht drüber.
Ist FPS nicht dein Nachname? Nein, wie kommst du da drauf?
Exposed!
Nee, das kann nicht sein, also das, dass das einer merkt,
habe ich nicht gedacht.
Liegt!
So. Ja, also Trextream
Ich hoffe, du kannst mir da einfach was anfangen.
So, und jetzt muss ich mal schnell durch den Chat scrollen, was, was
noch, weil wir waren gerade nämlich massig Fragen und ich habe davon
kaum, kaum was beantwortet, weil ich so sehr am Schwätzen war.
Übrigens die
Oh Chat!
Ist Scrum? Hat jemand gefragt.
Also zumindest so tun können, als ob
muss man heutzutage können, weil das ist eine beliebte Frage.
Das ist eigentlich, ähm,
also ich versuche das mal so in meinen Worten zu erklären.
Das ist eigentlich, äh, also eigentlich
ein Verfahren zur
Softwareentwicklung, wo es darum geht, dass man nicht
so die klassisch dahergebrachte Geschichte macht,
von wegen ein Projektmanager läuft im Kreis, fragt die Leute ab,
dann haben die Leute keinen Bock, dann wird irgendwelche
Ziele vereinbart drei Monate später, sondern es geht eigentlich eher da
drum, dass man sich, dass man sich Pakete nimmt
und die Entwickler quasi,
dass man den Entwicklern, dass man den Entwicklern mehr selbst
machen lässt.
Also dass man den Entwicklern mehr, und sagen
mehr, mehr Verantwortung gibt
und da hat man halt dieses ganze Scrum-Gedöns drumherum gebaut.
Also eigentlich ist es ein Projektmanagement-Verfahren,
wenn man es so will.
Insbesondere zur agilen Softwareentwicklung,
bla bla bla, Lean Development, was auch immer, genau.
Da gibt es dann solche Sachen wie das Scrum Master und der
Product Owner und das Entwicklungsteam und Sprints
und Zeug und haste nicht gesehen.
Aber eigentlich geht es da drum, dass die Entwickler
untereinander mehr eigenverantwortlich machen.
Und dass man nicht riesengroße
Dinge drei Jahre macht, sondern dass man immer wieder
zwischenzeitlich sagt, hey, was ist das, was wir schaffen
können und das dann macht.
Halt Agile oder Agile, wie das heutzutage so schön heißt.
So, ich muss jetzt mal von oben nach unten die
Fragen durchscrollen, weil sonst komme ich überhaupt nicht hinterher.
Nein, man trifft sich fünf Minuten am Tag und hat keinen Bock.
Ja, das ist das Problem, was viele daraus machen.
Ist ja bei uns auch so. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Keeper XY noch da ist.
Das haben wir auch so gemacht.
Also sprich, wir haben das einfach nur so genannt und
haben uns einmal im Tag in den Kreis gestellt, ohne dass man
wirklich das eigentliche, was Scrum bedeutet, gemacht hat.
So, also erst mal kurz hier durchscrollen.
Was habe ich denn für Questions alles übersehen?
Was machen wir heute? Du könntest eventuell Mikrotik mit
VLANs zeigen. Ja, das ist mir zu big brain heute. Das kriege ich nicht gemacht.
Außer wenn es zu spät.
Das machen wir aber nicht. Einen der nächsten Streams
machen wir das.
Was kann das liegen?
Das liegt daran, dass deine Tools wahrscheinlich nicht mehr laufen.
Ich auch.
Exzellent.
Logitech Support.
Ich habe fahre informatische System Integration gelernt. Ich habe nichts studiert.
Ich scrolle jetzt mal im Schnellverfahren den Chat durch.
Leaky Brain fünf Monate. Weiß ich nicht, ob ich gesehen habe.
Danke schön für den Sub. Musst du morgen auf die Arbeit fahren?
Nein, Fips muss ich nicht. Zum Glück kann ich wieder Homeoffice machen.
Welches Keyboard hattest du noch mal auf der Arbeit?
Mit Numblock. Das da.
Allerdings habe ich so Silikonringe.
Aber durchsichtig. So Silikonringe drunter.
Unter manchen Tasten, dass es nicht ganz so laut ist.
Weil die klickert relativ laut.
Ihr kennt es ja aus dem Stream.
Ich zeige es mal in der Shell.
Ich habe die Neigung dazu, dass ich etwas eingebe.
Und mir den Befehl noch mal angucke.
Und wenn ich sehe, dass der Befehl passt, dann haue ich immer so schön auf die Enter-Taste.
Und das mache ich auf der Arbeit auch.
Und unter der Enter-Taste ein Silikonring.
Was haben wir sonst noch für Questions?
Die Krauts abonniert drei Monate. Huge Subscription.
Ich habe hier ein 11-Head-Brain.
Da ging es darum, warum so viele Sachen nicht umgesetzt werden.
Obwohl beschlossen werden, dass sie umgesetzt werden.
Schreibt, ist wie die Frage, wer heute das Protokoll schreibt.
Labern können alle, aber umsetzen niemand.
Es ist halt die Frage, an welcher Stelle es hängt.
Bei uns würde ich sagen, hängt es an mehreren Stellen.
Warum Sachen nicht umgesetzt werden.
Auf der alleröberen Ebene ist es so, dass man gerne Innovationen verkaufen will.
Also sprich, dass man sagen will, ja wir haben ja jetzt quasi eine Arbeitsgruppe, die sich um dieses Thema kümmert.
Das wird geil.
Das Problem ist nur, sowas dauert ja ein bisschen.
Und das wird dann quasi oben schon als Wahnsinnserfolg verkauft, bevor das überhaupt richtig angefangen hat.
Und dementsprechend, wenn es dann richtig anfängt, interessiert es keinen mehr.
Weil man hat ja quasi schon das Prestige quasi da rausgeholt.
Das ist glaube ich zumindest bei uns das hauptsächliche Problem.
So, ich habe den halben Chat schon durch.
Kennst du eine gute Lösung zum Einlesen von NetFlow?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt gar keine Ahnung, was NetFlow ist.
Oh, Cisco.
Routers.
Nein, keine Ahnung.
So.
Also Ghostwriter schreibt, ich bin momentan in einem Krankenhaus an der Realisierung der Telematikinfrastruktur.
Das wird alles vom Bund gesteuert.
Bei den ganzen Abkürzungen raste ich jedes Mal aus.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ist bei uns auch so.
Ich glaube, umso größer die Firma ist, umso mehr neigen die dazu, alles abzukürzen.
Oh, Michael 50 Billion ist auch mal am Start.
Nice.
Exquisite.
Ja, manchmal muss ich Sachen halt auch mal doppelt erzählen.
Glaub gleich.
Hab ich es geschafft.
Im Chat.
Leco sagt, er benutzt jetzt auch Joblin als Note App.
Ja, das ist richtig gut.
Und ich hoffe, ich hoffe, die haben auch bald mal das App Icon gefixt.
Okay, also jetzt ich habe den Chat.
Ich habe es geschafft.
Allerdings ist die Sache die.
Jetzt gibt es ja heute ist ja hier hier Fragen bombandement angesagt.
Also Froschi sagt erst mal, ich habe eine Ausbildung.
Watt?
Hi, erst mal.
Ich habe eine Ausbildung zum Physi abgeschlossen und überlege nach Stütten zum Wirtschaftsinformatik
anzugehen, um gegebenenfalls neue und größere Aufgabengebiete zu bekommen.
Hast du Erfahrungen aus deinem Umfeld diesbezüglich?
Ja.
Ein Real Life Freund vom Friseur und mir hat auch Physi gelernt und hat dann Wirtschaftsinformatik
studiert.
Und bei dem war es so, dass das den Arbeitgeber irgendwie erst mal gefühlt gar nicht großartig
interessiert hat, weil er sich darum drücken wollte, ihm mehr Geld zu geben oder irgendwie
andere Sachen.
Aber mittlerweile und das ist jetzt irgendwie auch schon wieder zehn Jahre her, macht er
was anderes, läuft bei ihm ganz gut.
Aber so wirklich.
Das ist übrigens der, mit dem ich seit Jahren schon ein Video zum Informatikstudium aufnehmen
will, aber der sich immer davor drückt.
Der Mastercraber ist das.
Den kennt man vielleicht noch aus dem einen oder anderen Stream.
Der war ein paar Mal da, also beim Friseur im Stream.
Da Sebaro fragt, ob ich schon mal einen Windows Update Cache Server entzählt habe.
Habe ich auch nicht vor.
Hast du eine 3090 ergattert?
Nein, leider nicht.
Wie sieht es eigentlich aktuell aus?
Zeig mal her.
Ich habe vergessen, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe vergessen, das einzukaufen.
Angeblich gibt es das lieferbar.
Da habe ich aber so meine Zweifel, dass das lieferbar ist.
Das glaube ich erst, wenn ich sehe, dass das lieferbar ist.
Ja, natürlich.
Die Drecksäcke immer.
Machst du auch mal so einen Big Frame C Sharp Kurs?
Soll ich das machen?
Ich meine, wir könnten mal so einen C Sharp Beginner Kurs machen.
Da müsste ich aber wirklich erst mal in mich gehen und mir was Gescheites überlegen.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass es bei den neuen Custom Design Nvidia Grafikkarten von Zotac und Gigabyte Probleme gibt?
Was da sind die falschen Kondensatoren?
Nein, habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Das ist nicht so einfach aus dem Ärmel zu schütteln.
Da muss ich mir ein paar Basics-Themen überlegen, die ich in meinem Stream machen könnte.
Was stellst du dir vor, wo soll ich anfangen und aufhören?
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Was?
Moment.
Weißt du, wo im FireFox-Code der Print...
Ach du nein, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, ich habe in meinem ganzen Leben noch nicht in den Mozilla-Source-Code reingeguckt.
Nein, keine Ahnung.
Wobbly-Windows, die Liedungsbeste.
Nein, das machen wir nicht.
Froschi, Tier 1, Dankeschön, Exzellent-Subscription.
Da habe ich jetzt geschafft, den Chat durchzuarbeiten.
Exzellent.
Machen wir den Kram immer wieder zu.
Wo ich ursprünglich stehe.
Ach ja, ausgegangen sind das Ganze, als ich euch meine Heizungs-Datengeschichte gezeigt habe.
Ich bin begeistert, wie gut das funktioniert.
Hier sieht man, dass ich die Heizung eingeschaltet habe.
Irgendwann um 10 Uhr habe ich die Heizung eingeschaltet.
Seitdem sieht man, dass die Pumpe wieder läuft.
Der Brenner geht seitdem auch wieder mehr an.
Das hat sich echt gelohnt, diese Sache zu bauen.
Ghost Rider, zwei Monate, Dankeschön, Huge-Subscription.
Genau, da haben wir irgendwie heute gestartet.
Dann bin ich eine Stunde nicht mehr aus dem Schwätzen rausgekommen.
Wie gesagt, wie ich das gemacht habe, sieht man im Stream.
Im Archiv kann man sich das Ganze angucken.
Letztendlich ist es ein Raspberry Pi im Keller.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
So was wie User, Rechte, Verwaltung, Cron-Shops und so weiter wären interessant.
Das sind eigentlich die Sachen, die ich persönlich total langweilig finde.
Da müssen wir uns echt was überlegen.
Ein C-Sharp-Noob-Kurs, ein, zwei Streams, können wir im Stream zusammen machen.
Man muss aber sagen, es gibt ziemlich gute Kurse auf YouTube.
Allerdings nicht auf Deutsch.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es keine guten Kurse auf Deutsch gibt,
aber ich kenne keinen guten C-Sharp-Kurs auf Deutsch,
weil ich nicht nach deutschen Videos gucke.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass es keinen gibt.
Deswegen können wir mal ein, zwei oder drei Streams machen dafür.
Da muss ich mir aber was überlegen.
Aber Linux-Einsteiger-Stream fällt mir echt nicht als viel ein.
Da müsste man beispielsweise ganz simpel anfangen,
dass man sich mal irgendeinen Debian oder Ubuntu-Server installiert
und dann ein paar Basic-Sachen macht.
Ich glaube, es ist besser, wenn wir diese Sachen nebenher machen.
Ich mache hier öfters mal Linux-Geschichten.
Sei es die Steckdosenleiste-Flaschen,
wo wir irgendwas auf dem Raspberry Pi rumbauen,
oder den Traffic-Reverse-Proxy auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Dann ist es besser, wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt,
wenn ihr mich die Sachen fragt, während wir sowas machen.
Wir machen ja auch immer viele Sachen nebenbei.
Wir haben ja schon die ein oder anderen Vim-Shortcuts gemacht.
Immer mal wieder zwischendurch.
Wir können das tatsächlich machen.
Ich schreibe mir das nochmal auf.
Plus ein bisschen Git-Gedöns.
Shit.
So übertreiben das die anderen Hersteller eigentlich auch.
Ey, was für Dreck-Säcke.
Alter, PC-King.
PC-King.
Nie wieder PC-King.
Vorsicht, kaufen Sie nicht bei PC-King.
Okay, der Shop scheint zu sacken.
Wenn man 2,6 Sterne hat, ist es ziemlich Müll.
So, und wie sieht es bei den anderen aus?
Moment, ergeblich ist es doch lieferbar.
Schau wieder, PC-King.
Alter, diese Dreck-Säcke.
Das geht mir so auf den Sack.
Passt mal auf, wir gucken gleich mal auf Ebay.
Auf Ebay kann man jetzt den absoluten Bodensatz der Menschheit sehen.
RTX 3090.
Also neu kostet die glaube ich 1.499.
Ich meine, das wäre ich eventuell sogar neu noch bereit zu bezahlen.
Aber, erstens ist das eine Auktion und nicht direkt...
Das geht noch hoch.
Und es ist wahrscheinlich verkauft von privat an privat.
Was auch schon mal nicht so schön ist.
Warum will er 12 Euro versandt?
Macht er da Goldpapier drum?
Oder wird es noch höher versichert dann?
Weil ich glaube, das normale Paket geht auch nur bis 500 Euro, oder?
Ach, was auch immer.
Wurscht.
Ich kaufe mir erst wieder nächstes Jahr ein oder irgendwann wenn es...
Also jetzt steht es für mich fest.
Jetzt, nachdem der ganze Kram überhaupt nicht lieferbar ist.
Ich warte, bis es von AMD demnächst was gibt.
Es gibt ja schon die ersten Leaks dazu.
Und man spekuliert darauf, dass AMD jetzt irgendwann Ende September noch Anfang Oktober...
Warte mal, wie haben wir halt Oktober?
Äh, Saipen.
Heute ist ja eigentlich gar kein Stream.
Deswegen mache ich nichts, außer ein bisschen Fragen beantworten und Zeug schwätzen.
Was wir normalerweise machen, kannst du dir beispielsweise in den VODs angucken.
Da haben wir solche Sachen wie...
Äh, gestern haben wir ein bisschen an einem eigenen Webserver rum...
Alter, Max.
Das neue Twitch layout macht mich fertig.
Ähm, gestern haben wir ein bisschen an einem eigenen Webserver rumgebaut.
Einmal sonntags gucken wir uns ein paar Sachen zusammen...
Äh, hallo?
Ein paar Sachen zusammen an, dann haben wir beispielsweise letztes Jahr auch mal eine China Steckdosenleiste geflasht.
Und sind gescheitert, weil es den die falsche CPU hat.
Ähm, ab und zu kaufen wir ein paar Sachen ein, probieren ein paar Sachen auf Linux aus.
Kannst ja mal die VODs angucken, da siehst du was wir machen.
So, also für mich steht es jetzt fest, ähm, wenn AMD...
Oder, ich muss anders anfangen.
Also, nachdem er die 3090 absolut nicht lieferbar ist, steht für mich insofern fest...
Ich gebe keine 2000 Euro aus dafür.
Das sehe ich, das sehe ich nehme ich überhaupt nicht ein.
Zumal es sich aktuell ja eh noch nicht wirklich lohnt.
Mein 8700K mit der 1080 Ti ist mehr als schnell genug für alles was es aktuell so gibt.
Und das nach drei Jahren noch.
Ich sage zum hunderttausendsten Mal, dass das es früher nicht gegeben hätte.
Aber das hätte es früher nicht gegeben, dass ein PC drei Jahre äh...
Oberes, obere, obere Hälfte ist, ja.
So, und deswegen steht für mich fest, ich warte jetzt bis AMD mit den neuen CPUs rauskommt.
Weil bis dahin hat Intel auch ihr neues Zeugs am Start.
Oder Intel bringt ja jetzt gerade neues Zeug raus.
Ähm, und...
Dann gucken wir mal.
Entweder warte ich noch ein Jahr.
Man weiß ja nie.
Äh, oder aber, und davon gehe ich eher aus.
Ich kaufe mir Anfang nächsten Jahres oder noch kurz vor Ende des Jahres.
Wenn dann CPUs lieferbar sind, einen neuen Rechner.
Hi Max, ist eine 3080 keine Option?
Ja, theoretisch schon, aber die gibt es ja genauso wenig.
Die gibt es ja genauso wenig.
Ah, also.
Nein, das ist keine Option, weil die gibt es auch nicht.
Und, ja, natürlich ist eine 3080 nur Option.
Äh, spielemäßig macht es gar nicht mal so einen großen Unterschied.
Ähm, in normalen Auflösungen, mit normalen Framerates und all.
Also, für mich macht es wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel Unterschied.
Weil ich spiele die meisten Sachen nur auf 1080p.
Und auch meistens mit möglichst niedrigen Details für Maximum FPS.
Und gerade in diesem Full-HD-Bereich ist der Unterschied zwischen der 1080 und 3090 nicht so groß.
Können wir mal kurz gucken, ob es da irgendwie...
Hat die PC Games Hardware irgendwas?
Genau.
Ok, schauen wir mal Vergleich.
Äh.
Wo gibt es...
Haben die keinen Vergleich zwischen 3080 und 90?
3080?
Hä?
Das ist aber doof.
Äh.
PC Master Race.
Da haben die doch bestimmt irgendwas.
Ah.
Grafikkarten gibt das GPU Grill.
Wo gibt es denn da schöne Vergleichsbenchmarks?
Ähm.
Die Dinger sind meistens ziemlich am Mist.
Ok, was weiß ich.
Wir nehmen das Erste.
Also Vergleich.
Ähm.
3090.
Was ist denn FE?
Founders Edition.
Ah.
Also Stock.
Guck mal.
Da ist kaum ein Unterschied dazwischen.
Ich meine, das sind...
Was sind denn das?
5% oder so in dem Fall.
Ja, bei 8, bei 4K sieht es schon wieder ein bisschen anders aus.
Aber wie gesagt, ich spiele die meisten Sachen gar nicht in 4K.
Das ist aber eine bescheuerte Übersicht.
Hat irgendjemand nicht mal eine gescheite Benchmarks hier?
What the fuck?
Also ich muss sagen, in meiner Auflösung und mit meiner Vorlage ist der Unterschied wirklich
nicht groß.
Aber Linus Tech Tips.
Hat er da einen Vergleich drin?
Das da?
In dem da?
Ok, da scrollen wir mal kurz vor zu den Benchmarks.
Keine Ahnung wo.
Hat die Gamestar irgendwas?
Computer Base hat doch bestimmt was.
Ah, Pizzi Games Hardware habe ich nichts gefunden.
Da war ich gerade.
Pizzi Games Hardware war ich gerade.
Da habe ich nichts gefunden.
Komm mal, Pizzi Games Hardware.
Tests.
An die Seite, GPU Tests.
Grafikkarten Tests.
Genau, das hatte ich gerade auf.
Da ist kein Vergleich drin.
Darfst du Link posten?
Klar.
Das haben wir uns gerade angeschaut.
Ich habe keinen Vergleich gefunden zu 1080.
Ja, 11% Verdurchsichtigkeit.
Relanziert man auf ihre Performance im konsensuellen Spiel, ergibt diese Grafik im Vergleich mit
der GTX 3080 wenig Sinn.
Ja ok, das dachte ich mir schon.
Ich weiß, dass mir eine 3080 locker reicht.
Aber es geht ja nicht darum, was mir locker reicht.
Es geht halt darum, was ich haben will.
Ich weiß, dass mir eine 3080 locker reicht.
Mit Timestamp zur ersten Grafik.
Exzellent.
Das gucken wir uns gleich mal noch an.
Ok, erste Grafik.
Wo ist die Grafik?
Falscher Link, ich merke es.
Huge debate.
Aha, also Minecraft RTX muss es Minecraft sein.
Aber zumindest 4K.
Hier sieht man, der Unterschied ist nicht sonderlich groß.
Und bei 1080p ist das ganze noch geringer.
Wolf von Scharnjagdblatt, eines der größten Kackspiele der letzten Jahre.
In 4K, guck mal, das ist schon der Unterschied in 4K.
In 4K sind das, was sind denn das?
10% wenn es hochkommt, 10% in 4K.
Das ist in 1080p wahrscheinlich kaum messbar der Unterschied.
Aber ich will eine 3090 haben.
Ich weiß, dass das nicht rational großartig zu erklären ist.
Doch klar ist das rational zu erklären.
Denn ja, Schwanzvergleich, keine Ahnung.
Du hast doch im Leben kein Sample von einem 4050x.
Im Leben nicht.
Ego Slap.
Ach gesichtet, gesichtet.
Ich dachte, der hat eins.
Das ist auch ein bisschen GBA Titel.
Aber da kann er nichts für.
Da kann er nichts für.
Das schneiden die einfach ab.
Das schneiden die ab.
Da kann er nichts für.
Das unterstelle ich jetzt nicht, dass es absichtlich abgekürzt ist, dass man es nicht sieht.
Übrigens.
Kennt sich jemand von euch aus mit Material für 3D Drucker?
Weil die Sache ist die.
Also ich habe ja ich habe den hier, weil die Frage weiß jetzt schon kommt.
Ich habe das Teil.
Und da sind so ein paar Rollen dabei.
Also da ist eine Rolle dabei gewesen.
Und ein paar andere Rollen mit Farbe.
Aber ich habe jetzt letztens ein Video gesehen.
Da hat irgendwie einer, frag mich nicht, 15 verschiedene Materialien oder so vorgestellt.
Und da war schon extrem geiles Zeugs dabei.
Zum Beispiel hat er ein Material gezeigt.
Also das ist eine Abwandlung von diesem 3D Drucker Material.
Das sieht dann, wenn man das danach noch ein bisschen poliert, dann sieht das fast aus wie Metall.
Übels nice.
Und ich habe jetzt keine Ahnung von den unterschiedlichen 3D Drucker Material und ob ich damit meinen Drucker nicht kaputt mache.
Und vor allem das hat die übelst, guck mal das Zeug hat die übelst kryptischen Abkürzungen.
Ich blick da nicht durch.
Also ehrlich, ich hab da, ich checke es nicht.
Kann man das alles in den gleichen Drucker machen?
Oder kann man sein 3D Drucker damit schrotten oder so?
Ich habe echt keinen Plan davon.
Das ist auch schwierig, weil 3D Drucker ist irgendwie auch so ein Ding, wo sich die Leute gern gegenseitig flämen.
So nachdem, du hast diesen Drucker, mein Drucker ist ja viel besser.
Aber wie du drückst mit diesem Material, hättest du es mal mit diesem gedruckt.
Also da ordentlich Infos zu finden finde ich auch, verlässliche finde ich auch sehr schwierig.
Naja.
Das ist die Sound aus.
Nee, läuft noch.
Jaja.
Sag mal, Leute, ist es doch wieder Tag der Deutschen Einheit, oder?
Jetzt demnächst, weil es doch bald Oktober.
3. Oktober, exzellent, da gibt es dann bald wieder einen Tag.
Was ist denn das für ein Tag diesmal?
3. Oktober, 3. Oktober ist ein...
Ich hoffe kein Samstag, Sonntag, Montag oder Montag.
Ja, 3. Oktober.
Was?
Was soll denn das?
Hätten die sich nicht einen Tag früher vereinigen können?
Alter, Samstag.
Fils Batman.
Samstag, was ist das für ein Kack?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Könnte man das nicht irgendwie retro aktiv verschieben?
Könnte man nicht irgendwie klagen vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht,
dass das gar nicht am 3. Oktober war, sondern schon am 2. Oktober,
weil das ja eigentlich früher in Kraft getreten ist oder so?
Und das muss natürlich durch sein bis in 4 Tagen.
Was ist denn das Samstag?
Warum ist das Samstag?
Ich muss euch jetzt ehrlich sagen,
der eigentliche Anlass dieses Tages interessiert mich jetzt weniger.
Für mich ist einfach nur wichtig, dass man Tag frei bekommt.
Ich bin da wieder ganz selbstlos, wie immer.
Gefühlt ist jeder Feiertag dieses Jahr am Wochenende.
Weihnachten geht, glaube ich.
Wie fällt Weihnachten in diesem Jahr?
Freitag, 25.
Aber wenigstens 24.
24, 25.
Das geht doch halbweg.
Okay, es fällt nur einen Tag.
Okay, nur einen Tag auf Samstag.
Das geht schon mal halbwegs.
Und dann ist Silvester.
Silvester ist immer eine Woche nach Heiligabend.
Das heißt, es ist auch Donnerstag.
Das heißt, der 1. ist frei.
Das ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
Guckt mal, hier frei, hier frei.
Und dann noch mal Silvester und am 1. frei.
Das ist doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Es könnte besser sein.
Der 2. Weihnachtsfeiertag könnte auch noch am Wochentag sein.
Aber das ist okay.
Da kann ich mitleben.
Das ist in Ordnung.
So, der Nikolaus ist am Sonntag.
Advent ist ja immer am Sonntag.
Leider.
Ja.
Hätten ja auch an anderen Tagen machen können.
Aber nee, muss ja Sonntag sein.
Nikolaus ist eh egal, weil Nikolaus kann Feiertag.
Nächstes Jahr ist Freitag.
Okay, das sackt.
Oh, das ist mies hier.
Nächstes Jahr ist mies.
Alter, 2022 ist ja huge kacke.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Alter, ist das scheiße.
Weil die Sache ist die.
Samstag ist...
Montags habe ich ja auch frei.
Und dann ist hier Silvester...
Also 2022 ist ganz beschissen.
2022 ist echt Press F.
Er hat hier F in den Chat.
Aber erste 2022.
Nee.
Na gut.
Da kann man nichts machen.
Aber vielleicht bin ich ja bis 2022 Fulltime Twitch-Streamer.
Nee, garantiert nicht.
Max, ich habe negative Latenz.
Wieso hast du dir ein Stadia-Abo gekauft?
Oh ja, übrigens.
Ich muss mal kurz bei Amazon was gucken.
Ist jetzt absolut nicht IT-related oder so.
Haben die...
Ah, da kaufe ich mir eine Dose von.
Ich habe nämlich letztens in einem Video...
Ich gucke ja relativ viele Food-Logs.
Da hatte einer so eine riesen...
So eine riesen Box Kimchi.
Und da habe ich es mir aufgehalten.
Ich habe schon ewig keins mehr gekauft.
Und schon ewig keins mehr gegessen.
Da bestelle ich mir nachher noch eine Dose von.
Bakukki.
Kimchi.
Original Korean Recipe.
Hot.
Und das meinen die ernst.
Also je nachdem wie das ist, ist da Chili-Paste extrem.
Das haut dich weg.
Was ist das?
Im Prinzip ist das eigentlich nur eingelegter China-Kohl.
Ich glaube das ist eingelegter China-Kohl.
Koreanisches Sauerkraut mit Chili.
Aber es schmeckt gut.
Es ist eine richtig gute Mischung aus sauer und scharf.
Das schmeckt...
Das kann man wunderbar zu irgendwie Reis oder sonst was dabei.
Es schmeckt richtig gut.
Als alleinige Mahlzeit ist es nicht.
Aber so als dabei ist es echt sehr nice.
Gehst noch für Lebensmittel aus dem Haus?
Ja.
Das ist aber auch das einzige wo ich wirklich noch regelmäßig in Geschäfte gehe.
Das ist...
Also...
Wikipedia.
Das ist quasi eingemachter China-Kohl in der Dose.
Durch Milchsäure-Gärung.
Also sprich man macht das in eine Dose.
Oder Weißkohl nicht China-Kohl.
Ist China-Kohl nicht Weißkohl?
Es ist irgendein Kohl der kommt mit Chili-Paste und Gedöns zusammen in ein Glas.
Und dort lässt man den erstmal eine ganze Weile stehen.
Dann gärt das so ein bisschen vor sich hin.
So ein bisschen wie wenn die Oma früher saure Gurken gemacht hat oder so.
Und dann machst du es auf und es schmeckt finde ich ziemlich gut dabei.
Wie gesagt als alleinige Sache ist es jetzt nicht so geil.
Aber dabei finde ich schmeckt es wirklich gut.
Dein Vater macht das immer selber.
Das ist tatsächlich Poggers.
Oder Poggers ist das.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit deinen Kochkünsten aus?
Es geht.
Also die Basics kriege ich hin.
Ich habe früher recht häufig gekocht.
Aber jetzt die letzten Jahre schon gar nicht mehr.
Meistens irgendwelche Liefer-Service-Geschichten.
Wobei ich jetzt wieder...
Wobei ich jetzt überlegt habe ob ich nicht ein bisschen mehr anfangen kann.
Ob ich nicht ein bisschen mehr anfange.
Nachdem ich mir...
Habe ich euch eigentlich erzählt, dass ich zum ersten Mal eine meldepflichtige Krankheit hatte?
Ich habe Post vom Gesundheitsamt bekommen.
Und ich rede nicht von Corona.
Ah nice Dissorsion.
Da weiß ich ja Bescheid.
Gut zu wissen, dass sich hier einer auskennt.
Das ist nicht Corona.
Ich hatte...
Also ich habe...
Ich kann euch...
Also langsam Max.
Ich habe hier so einen Stream gemacht.
Da war ich krank.
Und ich habe gar nicht realisiert wie schlecht es mir eigentlich ging.
Weil wenn es einem so richtig scheiße geht.
Man merkt erst wenn es einem wieder besser geht wie schlecht es einem gegangen ist.
Irgendwo habe ich doch hier so einen ganz kurzen Stream gemacht.
Hier.
Da war ich nur 45 Minuten on.
Und da hatte ich auch Fieber.
Und ich habe mir irgendeine Lebensmittelvergiftung geholt bei einem Lieferservice.
100 pro bei einem Lieferservice.
Weil ich habe quasi die ganzen Tage vorher nur Lieferservice bestellt.
Und da war auch so Sachen dabei wie Salat mit Joghurtsoße und ähm...
Was war da noch dabei?
Rahmenschnitzel und solche Sachen wenn man da nicht aufpasst.
So.
Und da hatte ich...
Da war ich beim Doktor.
Beziehungsweise ich habe dort angerufen.
Der hat mir eine Krankmeldung ausgestellt ohne dass ich hingegangen bin.
Und ich habe aber noch mal eine Probe abgegeben.
Und das war im Labor.
Und dann habe ich eine Woche später.
Habe ich Nachricht gekriegt vom Gesundheitsamt.
Dass sie das Labor benachrichtigt hat.
Ich hätte eine meldepflichtige Krankheit gehabt.
Und zwar...
Wenn ich jetzt nur wüsste wie das...
Irgendein Bakter.
Bakter.
Ähm...
Meldepflichtig.
Bakter.
Im Darm.
Das da.
Ich glaube das da.
Den da hatte ich.
Das da hatte ich.
Exzellent.
Oder besser gesagt nicht exzellent.
Ah.
Ich glaube das war es.
Ja meldepflicht.
So jetzt kommen wir hier.
Symptome.
Symptoms.
Machen wir mal auf Deutsch.
Symptome.
Wenn ich jetzt noch richtig schrei... Alter!
Ich will das nicht auf Englisch haben.
Genau hier da steht es doch.
Häufig besteht...
12 bis 14 Jahre vor Auftreten.
Der blablabla.
Mit Fieber.
Kopfschmerzen exakt.
Ich hatte Fieber.
Über 39 Grad.
Da habe ich mir Zeug reingeschmissen.
Bauchschmerzen.
Dünnschiss.
Fieber.
Richtig beschissen.
War mega kacke.
Und...
Ich habe bestimmt was schlechtes gegessen.
Aber das ist was meldepflichtiges.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ja.
So und da musste ich so einen Zettel ausfüllen.
Vom Gesundheitsamt.
Und da musste man unter anderem angeben was man gegessen hat und wo man gegessen hat.
Und ob man in der Gastronomie arbeitet.
Wenn man in der Gastronomie arbeitet.
Sagen sie du darfst auf gar keinen Fall auf die Arbeit gehen.
Aber gut zum Glück arbeite ich nicht in der Gastronomie.
Zumindest.
Habe ich die zwei Lieferservice angegeben.
Wo ich bestellt habe.
Und ich bin mal gespannt ob die jetzt Besuch kriegen vom Gesundheitsamt.
Keine Ahnung.
So und das war wirklich ziemlich kacke.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes war das kacke.
Und mir ist wie gesagt.
Als ich hier gesessen habe und gestreamt habe.
Vor ein paar Wochen.
Mir ist gar nicht aufgefallen wie schlecht es mir ging.
Ich merke das jetzt erst wieder als mir wieder gut ging.
Ich habe im Bett gelegen.
Und ich konnte kaum aufstehen.
Jedes mal wenn ich aufgestanden bin habe ich so.
Alter du musst dich wieder hinlegen.
Übels kacke.
So erst im Nachhinein eingefallen wie schlecht das eigentlich war.
So und.
Also ich habe zwei Vermutungen.
Entweder der Döner Lieferdienst.
Bei dem habe ich nämlich zweimal bestellt.
Ich habe nichts gekriegt.
Ich habe das ging von alleine wieder weg.
Ich habe zweimal beim Döner Lieferdienst.
Bestellt.
Und einmal beim italienischen Lieferdienst.
Rahmschnitzel.
Rahmschnitzel mit Salat.
Und Salatsauce war so eine Joghurtsoße.
Da tippe ich ja irgendwie drauf.
Alternativ.
Ich habe auch einmal beim Döner Liefer Service.
Bestellt Döner Teller.
Das habe ich aber am Tag vorher gegessen.
Das wird es nicht sein.
Das habe ich aber am Tag vorher.
Irgendwas anderes dort auch mit Joghurtsoße.
Und ich glaube das.
Das oder das Rahmschnitzel und der Salat war es.
Serious Sam 4.
Ja das soll jetzt demnächst rauskommen.
Das werde ich mir holen.
Was für eine Tastatur hast du?
Also ich habe auf der Arbeit.
Habe ich die hier.
Mit Num Block.
Wohlgemerkt.
Also.
Ja Num Block.
Die da.
Habe ich auf der Arbeit und daheim habe ich die hier.
Allerdings.
Die ist kacke. Weil da ist mir gestern oder so die.
Oder vorgestern die.
Control Taste abgebrochen.
Was ziemlicher kacke ist für so ein teures Keyboard.
Warum mit Num Block?
Weil ich lieber auf dem Num Block tippe.
Irgendwelche Zahlen als hier oben auf dieser komischen.
Zeile da.
Also ich tippe gerne Num Block.
Um was gehts heute?
Heute gibt es gar keinen Stream.
Weiß gar nicht was du hier machst.
Ja so Num Block.
Du brauchst mal Setup. So was haben wir glaube ich.
Ich glaube wir haben Ausrufzeichen Hardware.
Aber das ist da fehlen Sachen.
Und das ist nicht aktuell.
Da muss ich mich mal hinsetzen.
Und den Kram aktualisieren.
Num Block ist das beste.
Das ist ja geil.
Ist das Fake?
Wenn die Kaffeemaschine
einen Verschlüsselungsdroianer drauf hat.
Ist das Fake?
Es kann schon.
Ich traue das heute alles zu.
Ich traue das heute wirklich alles zu.
Also demnächst meldet sich die Kaffeemaschine.
Hallo ich bin verschlüsselt bezahlen Bitcoins.
Nope ist real.
Wie viele Raspberries
und Microcontroller hast du eigentlich?
Das kann ich dir ganz genau sagen.
Weil ich habe nämlich für diesen Fall
eine extra Liste gemacht.
Weil das wird öfters gefragt.
Ach Serious Sam 4 ist schon raus?
Okay.
Das ist aber anscheinend nicht mehr so gut.
Ja also das kann ich dir genau beantworten.
Changer 6789.
Wenn ich das Textdokument finde.
Kann ich dir das genau sagen?
Wie hieß denn das?
Wie habe ich denn das genannt?
Das ist das vor Bodymass Index berechnet.
Wie habe ich das genannt?
Ja es ist immer gut wenn man sich die Sachen aufschreibt
und dann nichts mehr findet.
Oder habe ich das irgendwo unter Linux gehabt?
Tja wie habe ich das genannt?
Wie habe ich den Datei genannt?
Wo ich den ganzen Kram reingeschrieben habe?
Jetzt hast du mich ja was gefragt.
Ich dachte jetzt kann ich das easy as fuck
irgendwie aus dem Ärmel schütteln.
Das ist nicht so schlecht.
Wow.
Fuck.
Was ist da irgendwo drin?
Alles klar.
Tja.
Ok ich habe keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht haben wir es auch auf der anderen Vm drauf.
Ich habe das nämlich extra aufgeschrieben.
Wo ist der Kram?
Weil ich, ich krieg das aus dem Kopf nicht zusammen, das sind so viele Dinger mittlerweile.
Ähm, ah hier, da ist es doch, also.
Oh, ich seh jetzt schon, das ist nicht mehr aktuell, aber das ist auch die alte VM.
Kein Wunder, dass das nicht mehr aktuell ist.
Also, ähm, ich hab als erstes den Raspberry Pi für die Kamera am Hoftor.
Das ist eine selbstgebaute, selbstgebaute Geschichte mit einer Raspberry Pi Cam.
Die hab ich so eingestellt, dass sie tagsüber mit 15 FPS läuft und nachts, nachts läuft sie mit 2 FPS.
Weil wir haben direkt vor dem Hoftor eine Lampe.
Allerdings ist die Belichtungsdauer zu kurz bei 15 FPS.
Nach wieviel Tagen ging es dir besser? So 4-5, dann war wieder ganz okay.
So, und, ähm, wenn man die Raspberry Pi Cam, Kamera auf 2 FPS stellt und die, die Belichtungsdauer anpasst,
dann kann man auch, wenn dunkel ist, alles gut erkennen, ähm, halt wenn eine Lampe auf der Straße steht.
Weil ich wollte hier keine, keine irgendwie Infrarotbeleuchtung und so machen.
Also, das ist die erste Kiste für die Kamera am Hoftor.
Äh, Heizung, Statistik sammeln, das hab ich vorhin gezeigt.
Heizung, Statistik sammeln, äh, gibt's hier.
Dann den Octopi für die 3D-Drucke hab ich am Start.
Das haben wir ja auch zusammen im Stream gemacht.
Dann für drüben zum Fernseh gucken, Fernseh aufnehmen, äh, Media Center-Gedöns, ein Odroid HC2.
Das ist zwar kein Raspberry Pi, aber das ist auch ein Single, ein Singleboard-Computer.
Und Teil, kann man direkt Festplatte ranmachen, gut ist.
Haben wir, haben wir auch im Stream zusammen eingerichtet, weiß ich noch.
Haben wir, haben wir zusammen, damals haben wir glaub ich dafür extra eine neuere Linux-Computer kompiliert,
dass der meine TV-Karte erkannt hat.
Kannst ja noch einer dran erinnern?
Da war irgendwas, da war irgendwas.
Ähm, so, genau, dann hab ich unten im Keller Stromzähler für, für, für das Erdgeschoss, ersten Stock.
Das funktioniert relativ simpel, das ist ein ESP32, ESP866, ein, ich weiß gar nicht mal was genau.
Der hat einmal einen Sensor dran, der diesen Zähler hier auslesen kann.
Der hat einen Sensor dran, der quasi erkennt, wenn hier dieser, dieser Strich durchläuft, das ist richtig big brain.
Das ist einer meiner absoluten Lieblingskonstruktionen, die ich gebaut hab bisher.
Weil das so gut funktioniert und erst mal so ausgeschrieben hat, als würde das gar nicht funktionieren.
Das ist wirklich mittlerweile eines meiner absoluten Lieblingskonstruktionen geworden.
Der erkennt einfach, wenn hier der Strich durchläuft und zählt das dann.
Funktioniert ausgesprochen gut, ja.
Äh, und für den ersten, fürs erste, für den ersten Stock, äh, haben wir, hab ich eine, äh, quasi einen Sensor dran,
der das LED-Blinken von dem Stromzähler erkennt.
Trackst du auch Strom von einzelnen Geräten nur teilweise, nur dort, wo die, äh, Steckdosen oder sonst was dazugeben.
Beispielsweise von Wäschetrockner hab ich das, von Wäschetrockner hab ich das, da hab ich eine Z-Wave Steckdose dran,
die, äh, das messen kann, aber ansonsten eigentlich nicht, nee.
So, dann hab ich, äh, einen ESP32 vorne an der Tür hängen.
Der macht, äh, Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor von ein paar Pflanzen im Hof, dass ich weiß, wann ich, ähm, wieder
gießen muss.
Kannst du auch, ich, ich, ich mach mir schon die ganze Zeit Gedanken, wie man mal irgendwie eine Haustour machen könnte, ja.
Übrigens eine Sache, die hier noch dazugekommen ist, Klimaanlage,
äh, was, äh, einen ESP32 zur Klimaanlagensteuerung hab ich noch.
Dann für das Hoftor, der wird übrigens demnächst auch upgraded, dass der erkennen kann, wenn der Briefkasten auf und zu gemacht wird.
Der ist allerdings an der Batterie, deswegen ist es ein bisschen teureres ESP32-Bord, nämlich ein ESP32 Fire Beetle.
Das ist so, mit das beste Board, was man sich für Low-Power kaufen kann.
Kostet auch ein bisschen mehr, hat aber schon komplett Batterie-Ladeschaltung drinne und, äh, Batterie-Anschluss.
Und so gut wie kaum Verbrauch im Deep Sleep, deswegen hab ich das Ding.
Und der läuft bisher immer noch, das läuft aber nicht so lang.
Also, berechnungsmäßig hält die Batterie zwei Jahre, aber sag mal so, wenn den Jahr hält, ist gut, dann lad ich halt mal zwischenzeitlich wieder auf und gut ist.
So, ähm, für das Aufladen mach ich einfach ne Powerbank dran und gut ist.
So, ähm, genau, der Briefkasten, der wird demnächst damit verbunden.
Dann hab ich, ähm, ach ja, genau, ich hab das hier durcheinander gebracht.
Ähm, das ist per Low-Energy-Bluetooth.
Wie läuft das mit der Stromversorgung, wenn du einen Brief... Batterie, Batterie.
Deswegen sag ich ja, hab ich extra diesen Fire Beetle gekauft, ESP32, weil der im Deep Sleep kaum was verbraucht.
So, ähm, also dann hab ich noch was für, äh, zum Bodenfeuchtigkeitsauslesen an einem anderen Ort, das geht über LoRa.
Allerdings bin ich da gerade überlegen, ob ich das doch nicht besser über so nen billigen Mobilfunkvertrag mache.
Wie versteckst du die oder liegen die einfach frei?
Äh, ich hab mir für die meisten nen 3D Gehäuser ausgedruckt.
Ausm 3D Drucker. Der an der Tür ist einfach aufm Schrank.
An der Tür bei mir steht ein Schrank, da sind unten die Schuhe drin, oben stehen ein paar Kartons drauf und so.
Und das Ding liegt einfach aufm Schrank.
Aber die anderen, die auf Augenhöhe sind, die haben, äh, die meisten haben ein 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse.
So, ähm, und das ist eine Sache, die hab ich noch nicht fertig gebaut, und die funktioniert eigentlich richtig.
Ich wollt feststellen, mit nem, ich hab mir so nen Rüttelsensor gekauft.
Also der kann, der kann erkennen, wenns rüttelt.
Also wenns, wenns wackelt, da sind so kleine, kleine Gewichte drin und wenn die sich bewegen, dann erkennt man das halt.
Und sprich, dann erkennt man, wenn die Waschmaschine an ist, wenn die Waschmaschine an ist, dann rüttelt's.
Und wenn die Waschmaschine quasi danach wieder ausgeht, dann weiß ich, die Waschmaschine ist fertig.
Ist eigentlich ne ziemlich coole Konstruktion, aber da bin ich noch nicht dazu gekommen.
So, also das ist, das ist nicht aktuell.
Aber da fehlen wahrscheinlich sogar noch, äh, drei, vier.
Ich hab ja mittlerweile auch ordentlich wieder upgradet.
Ähm, wie gesagt, mir fällt jetzt spontan nur die Klimaanlage ein.
Den Unify-Controller, da steht der gar nicht drinne.
Warum steht da der Unify-Contro, aber da hab ich den vergessen.
Steht der Unify-Controller nicht drinne?
Den hab ich auch gar nicht, gar nicht drinstehen.
Ah, doch hier der Unify-Controller ist auch drin, sehr gut.
Excellent.
Naja.
Gut, ähm, ja, ich hab Frage beantwortet.
Also sind, sind ein paar mittlerweile, sind, sind, sind doch ein paar geworden, ja.
So, ähm, so, ich hab gesehen im Chat gab's noch ein paar Sachen.
Dann frag ich auch mal was.
Was denkst du von einer Do-it-yourself-Alarmanlage über Home Assistant mit Aquara-Sensoren?
Also die Aquara-Sensoren sind ziemlich cool.
Damit wollte ich auch mal ein bisschen rumspielen.
Allerdings hab ich mich dagegen entschieden, weil ich hab schon einige WLAN-Geräte,
ich hab einige Z-Wave-Geräte und ich brauch jetzt nicht auch noch ZigBee-Geräte dabei.
Warum, was dagegen, das ist das Einzige, was dagegen spricht.
Also eigentlich macht's keinen Unterschied.
Ähm, also es wird nicht schlechter oder so dadurch.
Aber diese Aquara-Dinger, die sind wirklich ziemlich gut.
Ähm, weil dann kriegt man ziemlich günstig Sensoren für.
Also wenn man, wenn man sich jetzt neu was baut und wirklich ein Budget macht,
sind diese Aquara-Dinger nicht verkehrt.
Zumal es da mittlerweile auf GitHub auch zig Projekte gibt,
wie man das Ganze auslesen kann ohne China Cloud.
Und ich find die Idee gut.
Wobei ich halt sagen würde, ähm, Dom PC, also
Do-it-yourself-Alarmanlage ist schön und gut,
wenn man es halt nur darum geht, dass man halt eine Alarmanlage hat, die halt eventuell geht.
Also wenn man jetzt halt keine Alarmanlage hat und man kommt gut ohne Alarmanlage aus,
spricht das nichts dagegen, eine Do-it-yourself-Alarmanlage zu bauen.
Allerdings, bei angenommen, man möchte jetzt wirklich was überwachen, wo es drauf ankommt.
Also bei angenommen, du hast ein Safe im Keller stehen mit 300 Millionen Trille.
Ähm, dann würd ich vielleicht keine Do-it-yourself-Alarmanlage machen,
sondern, ähm, mir irgendwas sichereres oder, ne, was, ne, was,
irgendwas erprobtes, zuverlässiges, äh, überlegen.
Weil es ist ja immer die Sache, ich, ich, ich geh auch davon aus,
dass man wahrscheinlich was besseres auf ein zugeschnitteneres selber bauen kann,
aber man weiß halt nicht, ob es im Ernstfall dann funktioniert,
wenn das erst seit kurzem eben am Start ist.
Das ist genauso wie mit meiner Überwachungskamera-Lösung, die ich da gebaut hab.
Ich hab mir selbst so ein Webinterface für Überwachungskameras gebaut.
Schön und gut, es funktioniert auch, aber ich verlass mich nicht drauf, dass es funktioniert.
Also ich hab jetzt nicht die Hoffnung, dass ich dort mal nachts drauf gucke
und irgendwie den Einbrecher erkenne im Hof oder sowas.
Also ich find's toll, der Phipps wusste das, andere Kiste, ich wusste auf die andere VM.
Ich, ich bin immer begeistert, wie gut, wie gut der Chat weiß, äh, was ich suche.
Eher Five Head Home.
Ja, ich bin schon, ich bin wirklich die ganze Zeit schon immer überlegen,
wie ich mal irgendwie ne Smart Home, Smart Home Tour oder sowas machen kann.
Da fällt mir ein, ich brauch unbedingt neue Batterien.
Ich brauch einmal, ähm, davon eine ganze, ganze Ladung wieder
und, oh, wie heißen die Dinger denn?
Da sind wir nicht grad bei AliExpress.
Ich hab ja diese Fenster, Türsensoren.
Ich hab ja diese Dinger hier als Fenster und Türsensoren.
Äh, Door, Sensor.
Ah, Alter.
Genau.
Ähm, die Dinger hab ich als, aber ich hab mir die mal gekauft,
wo es die im Sonderangebot für 11 Dollar das Stück gab.
Da hab ich mir irgendwie klein mal so ein 15er Pack oder so bestellt.
Was sind da für Batterien drinne?
Habt ihr ne Ahnung, was da, ah, da steht es doch drauf.
CR14250, weil davon sind jetzt fünf Stück leer.
So mehr oder weniger innerhalb von einer, aber auch fast zeitgleich leer gegangen.
CR142, was, was so geil ist das für ne Batterie?
CR14250. CR14250. Hab ich noch nie gekauft.
Was aber auch heißt, dass die jetzt ungefähr zwei Jahre gehalten haben.
Eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Ach danke, Disortion. Huge.
Das können, da können wir mal, ähm, falls Mods da ist,
man könnte aus dem Pastebin-Link mal, ähm,
einen Command machen, so Ausrufezeichen Smart Home oder irgendwie sowas.
Da könnte man immer nachgucken, wenn,
wenn es mal jemand fragt wieder, weil das wird ja öfters, wird öfters gefragt.
Oh, die Musik ist aus.
Und es ist, ne, haben noch Zeit.
Exzellent.
So, was kostet denn hier so ein Pack?
Der Kraft Max Set, alles klar.
Kann man, kann man sich irgendwie verlässlich ne, ne Batterienmarke kaufen,
wo man weiß, dass die was taugen?
Also wo ich bisher extrem schlechte Erfahrungen mit gemacht hab,
ist mit so komischen billigen, äh, ich hab mir mal irgendwie einen Zwanziger.
Die hier, ich glaub von denen hatte ich mir mal einen Zwanzigerpack gekauft.
Und die waren quasi gar nicht mal richtig voll.
Die hast du reingemacht, ne Woche später waren die, also nicht die da,
sondern von denen hab ich schon mal so einen Pack für die Fernbedienung gekauft.
In einer Woche war es wieder leer. Übels Müll.
Gibt es da irgendwas, was man sich bedenkenlos kaufen kann?
Also die Warta-Dinger waren bei mir totaler Crap.
Aber vielleicht hatte ich einfach Pech und der Hersteller hat die zu lang lagern gehabt.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Weil die sind immer schon günstig.
Was soll das aus dem Paste bin zu einem Command-Fan?
Äh, ich würd sagen Ausrufezeichen Smart Home oder sowas.
Aldi.
Da muss ich ja Real Life in irgendwelche Läden fahren.
Das machen wir nicht sowas.
Ich glaub, es geht los.
Dom-PC, das weiß ich nicht, wie das bei Zigbee ist.
Bei Z-Wave ist es so.
Also ich hab's für Z-Wave so gemacht.
Also Z-Wave ist eine Funk-Technologie.
Ein bisschen so wie WLAN.
Für IoT-Geräte, die besonders Strom sparend ist.
Und die standardmäßig schon so ein Mesh-Netzwerk aufbaut.
Was man bei Z-Wave machen kann, ich weiß nicht, wie das bei Zigbee ist.
Aber bei Z-Wave kann man Folgendes machen.
Ich hab in meinem Haus Steckdosen verteilt.
Die hab ich, glaub ich, irgendwann bei Notebooks billiger gekauft.
Hier, die da, die da.
Nee.
Das sind die nicht.
Steckdose.
What the fuck?
Wo ist das?
Gibt's das Zeug nicht mehr?
Das Ding.
Genau.
Davon hab ich 5, 6 Dinger verteilt im Haus.
Und bei Z-Wave ist das so.
Dass Geräte, die am Strom hängen, bauen dieses Mesh-Netzwerk weiter aus.
Das heißt, das ganze Haus ist damit quasi abgedeckt.
Der Z-Wave-Stick ist hier oben am Server.
Aber ich hab im ganzen Haus quasi die Steckdosen verteilt, dass das Mesh-Netzwerk aufgebaut wird.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, bei Zigbee ist das ähnlich.
Aber ich weiß es nicht, weil ich Zigbee nicht verwende.
Akkus nutzt du gern?
Akkuteile.
Okay, ich zeig mal her.
Oh.
Ah.
Da wirst du aber, wirst du aber.
Ich hab zugeknallt.
Was war das jetzt?
CR?
1?
4?
Schon wieder vergessen, wie der Kram heißt.
1, 4, 2, 5, 0, kann das sein?
Ah, die haben die gleichen.
Okay.
Ne.
CR?
Doch, das sind die.
Haben die gar nicht.
Ja, RIP.
Gibt's nicht.
Haben wir nicht.
Ja, dann doch hier Amazon.
Oder heißt es CR?
CR?
1,5.
Was In-Loop-Adapter von A auf C?
Baby.
Warum gibt es eigentlich so viele Formate für Batterien?
Ist doch total unnötig.
Aber ich meine, ich kann auch so welche holen.
CR?
1, 4, 2, 5, 0.
Nice, Sebao.
Batterietester.
Ich habe einen Batterietester, aber einen Aliexpress-Batterietester.
Da weiß ich immer nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
Da sind die Batterien danach wahrscheinlich mehr Schrott als vorher.
Ich habe eh viel zu viel Aliexpress-Zeug.
Okay, hat noch einen Link geschickt.
Warum versuchen die mir eigentlich immer Darmunterwäsche und so hier zu verkaufen bei
Aliexpress?
Wissen die irgendwas, was ich noch nicht weiß?
In der heutigen Zeit ja alles kein Problem, ne?
Sanjo.
Was bei Conrad soll ich gucken?
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Da haben wir sogar einen auf der Zeit in Frankfurt.
Conrada, alles klar.
Ich bin Privatkunde.
Ja, nimmt sich im Prinzip nicht so viel.
Die kann ich auch bei Amazon kaufen und gut ist.
Check mal dein Tinder.
Das wird es sein.
Aliexpress weiß das schon vorher.
Und bei der Gelegenheit kann ich dann auch sagen, ja, ich bringe dir auch eine schöne
Maske mit.
Und eine Drohne.
Die Zusammenstellung bei Aliexpress ist immer geil.
Erstmal Darmunterwäsche, also Photoshopped hoch zehn Darmunterwäsche, dann eine schöne
Maske, danach kommt eine Drohne.
Alles klar.
Ach ja, guck mal, das gibt es tatsächlich hier.
Warum die Suche nicht funktioniert hat.
Saft.
Die heißen wirklich Saft.
Meine Erfahrung mit Aliexpress top.
Also, ich hatte mehr Probleme mit Shops in Deutschland und Rückerstattung mit PayPal,
wie ich bisher mit Aliexpress hatte.
Bei PayPal ist es nämlich so, wenn du so einen Support Case oder Customer Case oder ich weiß
gar nicht, wie der Kram jetzt hier ist, Problem Case, Dispute, Dispute meine ich.
Wenn du so einen Dispute auf PayPal aufmachst, zum Beispiel, ich habe mir mal einen Server
Rack bestellt, so ein kleines, als ich noch gedacht habe, man kann das zumachen, aber
eigentlich habe ich da viel zu wenig Platz für.
Und das hatte eine Scheibe vorne und das ist hier angekommen und die Scheibe war komplett
kaputt.
Da habe ich so einen Dispute aufgemacht und das hat sich ewig hingezogen.
Und erst am letzten Tag hat dann dieser Shop angerufen und hat gemeint, behalten Sie es,
das Rücksenden ist ja viel teurer, als dass es sich irgendwie lohnt.
Bei Aliexpress ist es umgedreht, also sprich, wenn du so einen PayPal Dispute machst, dann
musst du dich darum kümmern, immer wieder meckern und der Shop muss quasi innerhalb
von einem riesen Zeitraum reagieren.
Bei Aliexpress ist es so, du musst markieren, also wenn der Shop sagt, er hätte es geklärt
und du reagierst nicht drauf, dann sagt PayPal alles gut.
Bei Aliexpress ist es umgedreht gewesen bisher, immer wenn ich da Probleme hatte.
Du machst so einen Dispute bei Aliexpress auf, dann muss der Shop antworten und wenn
du nicht sagst, dass du zufrieden mit der Antwort des Shops bist, dann kriegst du dein
Geld wieder.
Also die haben quasi die Beweislastumkehr da schon durchgedrückt bei Aliexpress.
Und ich hatte nie Probleme, also ich hab immer mein Geld wieder bekommen bei Aliexpress.
Ich hatte schon die ein oder anderen Sachen, die nicht geliefert wurden.
Ich überleg grad, was war denn das letzte, was nicht geliefert wurde.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das war.
Irgendwas, was ich nicht so dringend gebraucht hab.
Und da meinte der Hersteller, ja es dauert noch und da haben sie mir eine Versandbestätigung
geschickt und in der Versandbestätigung stand drin, dass die Versandbestätigung nicht
funktioniert und dann hab ich nach einem Monat oder so mal einen Case bei Aliexpress
aufgemacht und bei Aliexpress lief das dann so.
Ich hab gesagt, hier Shop hab ich nie erhalten, der Shop hat gesagt, ja bitte, wir brauchen
noch ein bisschen Zeit und hier haben sie nochmal die Versandbestätigung und da haben
sie mir die gleiche Versandbestätigung nochmal geschickt, die das letzte Mal schon nicht
ging und angeblich haben sie es nochmal neu verschickt und dann hab ich nochmal drauf
geantwortet, dann hat der Shop nochmal drauf geantwortet und dann hab ich einfach mal
zwei Tage nicht drauf geantwortet und dann hat Aliexpress schon gesagt, so nach dem
Motto, sind sie zufrieden mit der Antwort, bitte antworten sie und dann hab ich den Tag
nicht geantwortet, bam Geld zurück.
Also ich hab nicht geantwortet darauf und daraus haben die geschlossen, ich bin nicht
zufrieden mit dem Shop und bam Geld zurück.
Der Shop war wahrscheinlich ein bisschen stinkig danach, aber gut.
Na ich mein, wenn die sich schaffen in einem Monat den Gramm zu verschicken, also ich rede
nicht von ankommen, sondern von verschicken, selbst schuld.
Also wie gesagt, ich kann Aliexpress nur empfehlen und den Produkten zu trauen ist so eine Sache.
Ich würde bei Aliexpress, also was ich mir zum Beispiel bei Aliexpress nicht holen würde
wären irgendwelche Hygieneartikel.
Es war von Klopapier abgesehen, aber da gibt es ja die abgedrehtesten Sachen, das würde
ich nicht machen.
Also ich würde mir bei Aliexpress zum Beispiel auch kein Netzteil holen, was ich an 230 Volt
oder so anschließe.
Das ist mir bei Aliexpress ein bisschen zu gefährlich, das würde ich nicht machen.
Was ich bei Aliexpress mache ist, ich kaufe mir massenhaft irgendwelchen günstigen Elektronik
Kram und wenn das sowas ist, was du mit 3,3 oder 5 Volt betreibst, was soll großartig
passieren.
Übrigens Batterien würde ich mir auch nicht kaufen.
Batterien würde ich mir auch nicht bei Aliexpress kaufen.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, das muss nicht sein.
Gerade die fetten, gerade hier die 18650 oder 18650, wie spricht man diese Sorte Batterien
eigentlich ordentlich aus?
18650, so wenn die brennen, dann brennt es ordentlich, also da ist schon ordentlich Energie
drinne.
Das ist mir bei Aliexpress nichts.
Ja, China Böller Batterien 18650 oder 18650.
Ab 01.01.2021 steuern auch auf Einkäufe unter 26 Euro.
Ja, das nervt mich.
Aber Aliexpress hat da bestimmt ihre Mittel und Wege, weil Aliexpress, ich weiß nicht,
ob es legal ist, Aliexpress schicken ja die Schiffe gerne über die Niederlande und verschicken
es dann von dort weiter auf dem Landweg per niederländische Post.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Aliexpress die ein oder anderen Kennzeichnungstricks
hat und versuchen werden, das zu umgehen.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen, weil, ich meine, also ich habe schon Sachen in den USA bestellt,
die sind bisher jedes einzelne Paket beim Zoll gelandet, jedes.
Und das geilste war, weiß ich, ob ich das schon mal erzähle, ich habe mal sowas hier
bestellt, habe ich bestimmt schon mal erzählt, aber heute ist ja eh schon, ne wie hieß das
Ding?
Nicht Smartscreen, Ambilight, Streamscreen, ja ok, ich sehe schon, ich habe es schon,
ich habe es schon, genau, erzählt.
Ich habe mir sowas hier bestellt aus den USA und das ist beim Zoll gelandet.
Ich glaube, das gibt es mittlerweile gar nicht mehr.
Streamscreen, die Seite ist weg, ist Streamscreen dead?
Ja, Streamscreen ist ziemlich dead.
Was soll ich pre-ordern?
Wollt ihr mich skamasen oder was?
Streamscreen, was ist das?
Ok, das war etwas anderes.
Also zumindest, ich habe mir so dieses Backlight hier bestellt, was übrigens immer noch wunderbar
funktioniert, eigentlich auch eine richtig geile Sache ist, damit kann man quasi, das
ist so ein Ambilight für ein Fernseh, nur dass man kein Ambilight braucht, so sieht
das aus.
Also das sind so LED Stripes, LED Stripes, die macht man hinten am Fernseh rum und dann
vergrößern die quasi ein bisschen so das Bild.
Man kann also das Bild vergrößern, ihr wisst, wie ich meine, also sprich der Übergang von
Fernseh zur Wand wird angenehmer.
Das ist wirklich nice, also das ist echt gut das Teil, das funktioniert auch immer noch
gut.
Hab ich bestellt in den USA, ist beim Zoll gelandet.
Der deutsche Zoll war dann wieder, das war echt Bürokratie pur.
Die haben dann erst gedacht, das wäre ein Fernseh.
Nein, das ist kein Fernseh.
Das ist im Endeffekt ein kleines Paket gewesen, wie soll das ein Fernseh sein?
Das sind Lampen, habe ich versucht zu erkennen, das sind Lampen, die man an Fernseh klebt.
Ah nee, doch nicht Fernseh, aber doch hat das irgendwie, kann man damit was empfangen
und sowas.
Meine Güte, war das ein Akt beim Zoll.
Und am Ende habe ich da irgendwie noch mal ein paar Euro drauf bezahlt.
Aber also Versand, Zoll, Mehrwertsteuer, FAT und Gedöns, das war ungefähr noch mal die
Hälfte drauf am Preis, als das, was es ursprünglich gekostet hat.
Aber die beim Zoll waren geil.
Das ist ein Fernseh.
Nein, das ist kein Fernseh.
Das ist ein Licht.
Ja.
So und bisher aus den USA ist alles beim Zoll gelandet, was ich bisher bestellt habe.
Und bei AliExpress ist noch nie was beim Zoll gelandet.
Was mich dazu zu der Annahme verleiten lässt, AliExpress hat da irgendwelche, wie auch immer,
ob sie legal sind, weiß ich nicht, Tricks, dass die Dinger nicht beim Zoll landen.
Und ich vermute halt, dass die das in die Niederlande schicken mit dem Schiff oder mit dem Flugzeug
oder sonst wo.
Also ich meine, es ist ja bekannt, dass die, dass die Europa mit der niederländischen Post
irgendwie zusammen machen, da AliExpress und ich vermute einfach, dass die, genau, einmal
das, Arthias, einmal das, dass die, selbst wenn du, keine Ahnung, 200 Euro Elektronik
bestellst, dass die halt draufschreiben, Elektronik teile 13,50 Euro, oder dass die
irgendwie faken.
Also dass die vom Schiff abladen in den Niederlanden und dann wird halt einfach alles entfernt,
was irgendwie nach China aussieht oder so.
Auch dein AliExpress ist schon hängen geblieben.
Okay, das, wie gesagt, bei mir und ich habe auch relativ viel bestellt, ist noch nie was
hängen geblieben.
Klar, manchmal, manchmal, manchmal passiert es halt.
Ich glaube, es kommt aber auch ein bisschen auf die Bestellungsart an, die man dort auswählt.
Wo bei mir auch schon was hängen geblieben ist, ist Banggood.
Der Shop mit der besten, mit der besten Seitenbezeichnung, Alter, Banggood.
Bei denen ist auch schon was hängen geblieben.
Oder was Gearbest, nee, bei Gearbest ist was hängen geblieben.
Haha, stimmt gar nicht.
Gearbest ist was hängen geblieben.
Banggood ist, glaube ich, auch noch nix hängen geblieben.
Allerdings muss man bei Banggood darauf achten, dass man das richtige Versand auswählt.
Zwar nehmen wir jetzt mal das hier.
Äh, und, nein.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich auch geht.
Du musst Euro Priority Line nehmen oder sowas, wenn es das gibt.
Ja, das ist, das ist was.
Hier, EU Priority Line müsst ihr nehmen.
Also das hier ist wahrscheinlich auch okay, Banggood Express.
Aber ich habe auch mal einen Post drüber gelesen, dass das die Geschichte wäre, die
am wenigsten im Zoll hängen bleibt.
Aber wie gesagt, bei mir ist auch so noch nie mal Banggood was hängen geblieben.
Nur mal eine gute Sache, was Banggood hat, man kann die Suche filtern.
AliExpress hat ja auch die Möglichkeit, dass man Sachen bestellt aus Europa.
Also sprich, angenommen das hier.
Weiß nicht, ob die das haben.
Guck, das hier gibt es beispielsweise auch aus China, aus Russland oder aus Spanien.
Und viele Sachen auf AliExpress kann man mittlerweile auch aus Frankreich, UK oder sonst wie bestellen.
Dann hast du da eh weniger Probleme.
Das Problem ist nur bei AliExpress, dass man nicht suchen kann nach dem Standort so richtig.
Bei Banggood geht das.
Deswegen ist es gar nicht mal so verkehrt, bei allen den China Shops mal zu gucken, bei
ein paar China Shops zu gucken, wenn man was bestellen will.
Genau.
So.
Ghost Rider schreibt, er hat sich ein Android Radio für 600, was denn?
Android Radio für 600 Euro, Poggers, äh.
Die haben Warenwert 98 Euro angegeben.
Deco Commodits.
Die wissen halt, wie es geht.
Was? Und ab 1.1.?
Zoll, was ändert sich da?
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Ich meine mal ernsthaft.
Bezahlen wir nicht schon genug Steuern?
Jetzt, jetzt mal, jetzt mal, wie der Grabu mir jetzt sowas sagen will.
Und ich, ich habe ja gar kein Problem damit, Steuern zu bezahlen an sich.
Was mir auf den Sack geht, ist, dass ich nicht das Gefühl habe,
dass meine Steuern für Sachen in meinem Interesse verwendet werden.
Oder zumindest nur zum verschwindend geringen Teil.
Wie sollen meine Steuern verwenden für Infrastrukturausbau, Internet, Bahnen, sowas, ja?
Straßen, Kindergartenplätze, Krankenhäuser, Gesundheitszeug.
Und nicht für das Restaurieren von irgendeinem Schiff oder irgendwelche Berater
oder irgendein anderes Geschiss.
Wie gesagt, ich habe keine Probleme Steuern zu bezahlen.
Ich würde auch nur sehen, dass für die Menschheit was ankommt irgendwie.
Das sehe ich nicht.
Tja, und deswegen frage ich mich, ey, kann man das den Leuten nicht mal gönnen?
Ja, und wenn Wish Mainstream wird, dann wird Wish halt Mainstream, okay.
Das ist doch gut, ich meine, wer bei Wish, jetzt mal ernsthaft,
wer bei Wish bestellt, der hat, glaube ich, eh die Kontrolle über sein Leben verloren.
Chat, habt ihr schon mal was bei Wish bestellt?
Warum bestellt man ein, jetzt mal ernsthaft, ich habe noch nie bei Wish was bestellt,
deswegen habe ich keine Ahnung davon.
Aber was ist der Vorteil von Wish versus ich bestelle bei AliExpress, Banggood oder GearBest?
Es ist doch eh China-Kram.
Also warum über Wish?
Ich meine das ernst, habt ihr da irgendeine Begründung dafür?
Warum soll ich China-Kram über Wish kaufen anstatt über AliExpress?
AliExpress hat kein Instagram-Marketing.
Er spricht eher für AliExpress.
Dafür haben die wahrscheinlich WeChat-Marketing.
Athias sagt, Wish ist halt AliExpress für Normies.
Das wird sein, ja, du hast recht.
Du hast recht, da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht.
Klar, ich habe jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht.
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht.
Du hast recht, da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht.
Klar, ich meine vergleiche doch mal die Seiten.
Also, was sieht...
Alter Internet-Explorer.
Chrome.
Also welche Seite sieht eher danach aus, als würde da dein 0815-Noop bestellen?
Die oder die?
Die hier sieht aus wie irgend so 0815, frag mich nicht, Ebay-Facebook-Verschnitt.
Und die hier sieht aus wie ein China-Scam-Shop.
Auf den ersten Blick, so.
Das heißt, der Noob bestellt natürlich dann lieber da, obwohl er besser da bestellen sollte.
AliExpress hat auch eine App, aber die ist...
Die ist richtig scheiße.
Mal gucken, ob es davon Bilder gibt.
Die ist richtig schlecht.
Ja.
Es ist im Prinzip die Webseite, nur dass die dich übelst vollkleistert.
Also, die AliExpress-App ist wirklich richtig...
Alter, die ist richtig kacke.
Die ist genauso kacke wie die Webseite, nur in App-Form.
Es ist ja auch im Prinzip die App-Seite, also die Seite nur mit...
Also, das ist wirklich mies.
Also, die AliExpress-App...
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die so gute Bewertung hat.
Wahrscheinlich die ganzen Chinesen.
Ja, exakt, die App ist übelst confusing und voller Bait.
Also, ich mag die AliExpress-App überhaupt nicht.
Deswegen habe ich die auch nirgendswo mehr installiert.
Wie sieht eigentlich die Banggood-App aus?
Ein bisschen abgeguckt von Amazon ist das Logo schon, finde ich.
Zwar nicht so weit, dass man da jetzt was sagen kann, aber...
Also...
Hä?
Also, ein bisschen Amazon ist in dem Logo schon, oder?
Finde ihr nicht auch?
Also, so ein bisschen...
Also, man könnte sagen, sie haben sich doch recht stark von Amazon inspirieren lassen.
So.
Warum braucht man eigentlich den Account, dass man sich den Shop überhaupt angucken kann bei Wish.com?
Okay, ich melde mich jetzt bei Wish an.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
10-Minute-Mail.
Ich habe, ich habe, ich war legit noch nie in meinem Leben bei Wish angemeldet.
So.
Last name, eh, first name Lul, last name KeckW, e-mail-address, eh, Passwort.
Passwort.
Hallo.
Never.
Tell us more about yourself, eh, man, how old are you, eh, nein, oh, oh Leute, ich bin schon so alt, finde ich.
Block.
Ey, der sieht, der sieht original aus wie AliExpress.
Also, dieses Pop-Up hier.
Ha, Sebaro, hast ja recht.
So, und warum, warum, warum sollte man da jetzt drauf gehen?
Local.
Äh, Alter, was ist das?
Fahrradschloss.
Sowas kriegst du bei AliExpress für 2 Euro und es ist wahrscheinlich kaputt, wenn du es anhustest.
Was ist das? Ich erkenne gar nicht, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Eine Lupenbrille mit einem exquisite Review.
Äh, Top 5 Sachen, die du bei AliExpress gekauft hast und begeistert hast, hm.
Also, die Top-Sachen kann ich jetzt gar nicht genau sagen.
Ich hab halt viel Elektronikkleinkram gekauft, wo man jetzt, da kann man jetzt wenig drüber hervorheben, ja, also.
Doch, also meine Top-Sachen sind die 50 USB-Kabel für irgendwie unter einem Euro das Stück.
Die waren top, die waren exzellent.
50 USB-Kabel für unter einem, 2 Meter USB-Kabel, 50 Stück, für unter einem Euro das Stück mit Micro-USB und, äh, USB-C in einem.
Äh, Shingi Kuro, 14 Monate, das ist ja schon ein richtiger Dankeschön für die 14 Monate Subscription.
Was ist das für ein Müll, warum soll ich...
Achso, das ist ein Schloss, okay.
Was ist das?
Was ist das, Leute?
1,02 Euro, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Feinkost-Lahn.
Make-up-Schwamm.
Und den hat er in die Pflanze ge...
Okay, guck mal mal im Vergleich, was hier die, was so, ähm, was hier der Kram kost...
Ähm...
Okay, die habe ich mir als letztes erst bestellt, die gibt's hier gar nicht, T-Display.
Die Seite leckt, as fuck.
Okay.
Das ist schon relativ günstig.
Also viel teurer, viel teurer als bei AliExpress ist das nicht.
Ach, das ist auch, das ist auch 95% off.
Ja, Moment, was denn jetzt?
Hä?
Ähm...
Ja, was ist es denn jetzt?
Ist es ein ESP32-CAM oder ist es ein NodeMCU?
Ah. Aha.
Alter, D1-Mini kostet 23...
Naja, gut, das ist jetzt auch nicht so viel. Das ist ein ESP82-66...
Ach nee, das ist die, ähm... Hä?
Das verwirrt mich. D1-Mini ist eigentlich ein ESP82-66.
Ist klar, ist das eins zu eins der von...
Aber die hier, wisst ihr, gebaitet.
Wetten das nichts?
Das ist bait. Das ist übelst gebait, als würde das sonst 52 Euro kosten.
Als würde das sonst 52 Euro kosten.
Wir warten mal, wir warten mal, was passiert, bis die Zeit abgelaufen ist.
Ich lasse jetzt die Zeit abgelaufen.
Mal gucken, was es danach kostet.
So, was kostet es bei AliExpress?
Ist Wish an Seite wenigstens sicher?
Oder versuchen die einem irgendwelche Mail-Win-Tipps?
Okay, also bei...
Bei AliExpress kostet der gleiche weniger.
Aber das ist die ESP82-66-Variante.
Also bei AliExpress kostet es die Hälfte ungefähr.
Was, ich soll den Tag noch ein bisschen abholen?
Was, ich soll den Text lesen?
Okay.
Use repulse the CP 2102.
What?
Nein, neben dem Text.
Instant offer add to your...
Oder was, was soll ich lesen, Schat?
Ach, ich muss es in den Warenkorb tun, dass der Preis lower wird.
Nee, ich muss es in den Warenkorb tun, dass der Preis so low bleibt, oder?
Ich warte mal ab, was passiert, wenn die Zeit abgelaufen ist.
Ich warte mal, was passiert, wenn die Zeit abgelaufen ist.
Ich habe mich noch nie bei Wish angemeldet.
Ich muss danach übrigens unbedingt meinen Browser-Cache leeren.
Weil ich will nicht, dass mich Wish trackt oder sowas.
Ich bin ja auch blöd.
Ich habe es ja auch nicht im Incognito-Tab aufgemacht.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Oder ist es im Incognito-Tab?
Die Mail habe ich im Incognito-Tab aufgemacht.
Genau, da kommt gleich NordVPN-Werbung.
Was passiert, wenn der Kram abläuft?
So, aber ich habe jetzt immer noch keine schlüssige Erklärung gefunden,
warum man bei Wish bestellt und nicht bei AliExpress direkt.
Außer halt die Noobs, die es nicht besser wissen.
Aber Vorteile hat man da noch gar nicht.
Also mal angenommen.
Also mal angenommen, man weiß, dass AliExpress existiert und man dort bestellen kann.
Man weiß, dass Banggood und Gearbest und sonst was existiert.
Gibt es dann einen Grund, bei Wish zu bestellen?
Also mir ist klar, dass die Noobs bei Wish bestellen.
Aber gibt es einen sinnvollen Grund?
Ach so, du kannst manchmal bei jemanden zusammen bestellen und Rabatt.
Okay, das ist natürlich, je nachdem, was es ist, recht sinnvoll.
Okay, expired.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Oh, es ist...
Alter, warum leckt die Seite so?
Moment.
Ich muss mal gucken, wie viel...
Der Bitcoin-Mind bestimmt im Hintergrund.
Pass mal auf.
Na ja, macht er nicht.
Ich hätte gedacht, der Bitcoin-Mind wahrscheinlich im Hintergrund, Wish.
Ah, null.
No.
Die Seite leckt, as fuck.
Also es ist vollkommen egal, ob das Ganze abgelaufen ist oder nicht.
Yes.
Was eine Kackseite.
Übelster Müll.
Blitzball.
Alter, was eine Kacke.
Geh fort.
Da werde ich nie was kaufen.
Okay, history.
Clear browser history.
Last 24 Stunden.
Alles weg, bam.
So.
Bye bye, Wish.
Warum wird das GIF eigentlich so schnell abgespielt?
Die anderen GIFs sind okay.
Die anderen GIFs sind alle okay.
Aber das CloGIF ist hyper shit.
Überprüf mal WireShark, wenn du Wish aufhast.
Na ja, das ist über HTTPS, da sehe ich nicht viel.
Außer, dass das massig HTTPS-Request macht.
Wish.com malware.
Gibt es da irgendwelche Sachen zu?
Wish.com save.
Reddit ist ja auch gerade exquisite schnell.
Oder habe ich mir schon den Wish Keylogger eingefangen?
Save, yes.
Alles kacke.
Ja, okay, klar.
Naja.
Ja, aber das ist, also diese Sache finde ich wirklich blöd.
Wie zieht man sich malware ohne Extension hinzuzufügen
oder Dateien herunterzuladen?
Zustand schwieriger, aber nicht ausgeschlossen.
Nennt sich dann Drive by Browser.
Nennt sich dann so.
Dazu bedarf es aber eine Sicherheitslücke in deinem Browser,
dass das funktioniert.
Und mittlerweile ist Chrome und Firefox,
gerade wenn man irgendwelche Adblock und sonstige Security-Sachen hat,
ziemlich sicher.
Also die Ultrasicherheitslücken, wie man das früher von Windows XP
oder der Explorer kennt, gehören der Vergangenheit an.
Hast du dir CAS im Web irgendwo installiert?
Ja, aber habe ich nicht mehr gestartet
und ich habe nicht dran gedacht, sonst hätten wir es darüber machen können.
Weil genau für sowas war das eine gute Sache.
Also heute fängt man sich deutlich nach Herzenbau.
Aber ihr wisst ja, passt voll.
Ist ja auch egal.
Ich gucke ja, also Wish werde ich nie was bestellen.
Da gehe ich lieber zum Original.
Da gehe ich lieber gleich zu AliExpress.
Hat das Stream gerade geleckt?
Nö, hat er nicht.
So, Saft.
Das war heute ein richtig sinnloser Stream, oder?
Wir haben eigentlich nichts gemacht.
Ich habe einfach mal 2 Stunden 40 bisschen geschwätzt.
Hi Chef, wie geht es?
Mir geht es gut.
Gerade noch.
Warum muss ich wieder arbeiten?
Hast du zufällig auch Homematic bei dir im Einsatz?
Nein.
Ich habe als Wireless Technologie für mein Smartphone C-Wave und ein paar Wi-Fi Geschichten.
Die hauptsächlich Wi-Fi Sachen, die ich habe, sind halt ESP32, ESP866 oder Geräte damit.
Zum Beispiel die Dinger.
Das sind eh die besten.
Die Shelly Relays sind absolut Pog.
Die sind Poggers sind die.
Beste, beste.
Aber ich habe kein Homematic, nee.
Ich brauche auch nicht noch mehr Wireless Geschichten.
Das Höchste der Gefühle wird eventuell vielleicht noch mal Zigbee sein für die ein oder anderen Sachen.
Aber so wie es aktuell aussieht, bin ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden aus der Mischung aus C-Wave und WLAN.
Also Wi-Fi und ich sehe jetzt erstmal keinen Grund dazu, das zu ändern.
Die Haut ist kein Organ.
Hat mit Twitch Prime abonniert.
Das ist gut zu wissen, dass die Haut kein Organ ist.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Hast du Shellys verbaut? Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe mir mehrere gekauft, verbaut habe ich nur den hier.
Ich habe mir noch die, die Strom messen können gekauft.
Weiß jetzt gar nicht, über welcher das war.
Könnte der gewesen sein?
Nee, Shelly EM haben wir, oder?
Nee, den wollte ich mir kaufen. Den habe ich mir nicht gekauft.
Da habe ich mir nämlich überlegt, ob ich das nicht als Ablösung zu meiner selbst gestrickten Lösung verwenden kann.
Wenn die Stadtwerke mir irgendwann mal ein smartes oder nicht so smartes Stromzähler einbauen.
Weil dann das Auslesen nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Aber die Shellys kann ich empfehlen, die sind wirklich top.
Ich glaube, ich bin der Einzige auf der Welt, der Heimautomatisierung macht.
Halbwegs gescheit programmieren kann, sich für Microcontroller, ESP, 32, 82, 86 und sonst was interessiert.
Und der nicht ein Sonoff bei sich daheim hat.
Die Sonoff-Dinger ist eigentlich das Ding schlechthin, was alle irgendwo in ihrer Heimautomatisierung drin haben.
Diese Teile.
Das ist quasi auch ein Remote-Schalter, den man flaschen kann mit das Motor.
Und dieses Ding haben sie alle.
Gibt auf YouTube Home Automation einen Sonoff-Videos, wirst du zugeschissen mit.
Ich habe nicht eins.
Und das liegt daran, weil ich das System irgendwie fragwürdig finde.
Also erstens ist der Sonoff zu fett.
Den Sonoff kriegst du nicht in den Schalter rein.
Es gibt mittlerweile einen neuen Sonoff, der auch theoretisch unter den Schalter passt.
Aber der alte Sonoff, die waren alle zu fett.
Und ich finde das Sonoff-Konzept fragwürdig.
Weil das Sonoff-Konzept basiert ja darauf, man nimmt das Kabel und schneidet das auf und macht die Kabel von Hand da innen rein.
Also so hier in die Richtung.
Nee.
WTF, warum?
Also den Sinn von den Sonoffs hat sich mir nie erschlossen, großartig.
Gutes ESP32-Board kommt auf den Einsatzzweck an.
Wenn du einfach irgendwas haben willst, wo ganz gut dokumentiert ist, welche Pins was sind und was alle Funktionen hat.
Zum Entwickeln nimm ein NodeMCU, wo gut ist.
Da kannst du dir dann allzu viel falsch machen.
Am besten gleich den Dreierpack.
Und wenn du Zeit hast, bestell's bei AliExpress.
Nur mal so, dass man den Preis, dass man den Unterschied sieht.
Hier kostet so ein Ding 3,42 Euro und in Deutschland kostet es 7,99 Euro.
Also wenn du Zeit hast, bestell's bei AliExpress.
Dauert halt ein bisschen.
Dauert halt einen Monat.
Du findest bestimmt auch welche, wo du es schneller kriegst.
Was ist mit euch los?
Wer macht denn sowas?
Ich bestell mir doch kein 3,42 Euro Mikrocontroller und mach dann 71 Euro Versand.
Das wäre hingeblieben.
Also Captain Peng, ohne näheren Einsatzzweck, hol dir einen Dreierpack NodeMCU und gut ist.
Da hast du alles dabei, was du brauchst.
Die Dinger sind recht verträglich.
3,3 Volt, 5 Volt geht damit.
Die verrecken halt auch nicht so einfach.
Die Pin-Beschriftung ist gut.
Die Beschreibung im Internet ist gut.
Du hast genug Stromanschlüsse.
Du hast glaube ich 2x3,3 Volt.
Ne, 1x3,3 Volt und 1x5 Volt.
Ich bilde mir ein, du hast 2x3,3 Volt.
Du nicht?
2x Crown, 1x da, 1x da.
Hätte gedacht man hat 2x3,3 Volt.
Na gut.
Dann nicht.
Ist halt besonders sicherer Versand.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wofür sich das NodeMCU absolut gar nicht eignet ist Batteriebetrieb.
Kannste komplett knicken.
Weil die schalten den USB Anschluss nicht aus.
Also sprich selbst wenn du das von Batterie betreibst ist komplett USB immer funktionsfähig und zieht unglaublich viel Strom.
Für Batteriebetrieb.
Also sprich der hat dann im Deep Sleep 110mAh oder so.
Das heißt du hast dann ein paar Tagen ist die Batterie leer.
Also der ist gut.
Und mein neues Lieblingsboard ist ja das hier.
Einfach wegen dem Display.
Wie gesagt auch Aliexpress kaufen.
Das ist so mein aktuelles Lieblingsboard.
Weil wie gesagt es ist ein bisschen teuer auf Amazon.
Weil richtig großes schönes Farbdisplay wo man ordentlich Sachen mit machen kann.
Halbwegs gute Anzahl an Pins.
Du kriegst 2x3,3 Volt auf den Pins.
Was ich recht praktisch finde.
Wenn man da mehr als ein Sensor.
Also das hat was.
Klar man kann auch einfach beide an einen anschließen.
Das geht auch.
Einmal 5 Volt mehrfach Ground.
Genug GPIOs.
Und was auch recht praktisch ist zwei Buttons.
Und das sind richtig echte Buttons.
Und hier neben hast du noch ein Reset und Flash Button falls man den braucht.
Die haben keine Funktionen eingebaut die man nicht überschreiben kann.
Die kann man als Buttons verwenden.
Und die Kombination aus hier den Pins.
Dem recht großen ganz guten Farbdisplay.
Und den zwei Buttons ist das gerade so mein aktuelles Lieblingsboard.
Die halten offiziell halten die glaube ich bis zu 12 oder 18 Volt aus.
Aber ich habe es mal probiert.
Also warte mal.
Ich überlege gerade.
Den Devon Mini habe ich geschrottet.
Aber den NodeMCU ESP32.
Die hat das glaube ich ausgehalten.
Oder 12 Volt.
Ok guck mal der macht bis 12 Volt.
Ah angeblich sogar 20.
Nee 20 würde ich da nicht drauf geben.
Die Sache ist halt die.
Das geht auch nur über USB.
Ich glaube das mit dem VIN würde ich nicht so.
Oder vielleicht geht der VIN über den gleichen Spannungswandler.
Kann sein, dass VIN und USB über den gleichen Spannungswandler geht.
Aber 20 Volt würde ich nicht machen.
Weil selbst wenn es das aushält.
Das Ding fängt ja gefühlt an zu klühen.
Genau das wird heiß.
Ja richtig das ist das worauf ich jetzt raus wollte.
Das wird richtig richtig hot das Ding.
Also mit 9 Volt weiß ich es nicht.
Aber mit 12 und gar 18 garantiert.
Ja.
Sibaro ist wieder hier am Chat ablecken.
So es war ein schöner nicht vorhandener Stream.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Und vorhin nochmal eine Runde aufs Klo.
Schön dass so viele dabei waren.
Obwohl es total random war.
Ich glaube ich habe keine Fragen übersehen.
Ne passt.
Wir machen Schluss.
Wir sehen uns Chat.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Machts gut.
Bis denn.
Tschüss.